du jour appelle les questions au
Gouvernement et la première question va
être posée par Madame Chantal Jourdan
pour le groupe socialiste merci madame
la Présidente en préambule avec mon
groupe nous souhaitons rendre hommage
aux gendarmes Jean-Christophe Bolloc'h
tué dans un accident cette nuit alors
qu'il effectue une opération antidrogue
nous pensons également aux autres
gendarmes blessés
[Applaudissements]
ma question s'adresse au ministre de la
santé et de la prévention samedi plus de
4000 soignants en pédiatrie ont adressé
une lettre ouverte au président de la
République alerte tant sur la situation
de crise que connaissent les services
pédiatriques notamment à l'hôpital
public cela fait seulement deux semaines
que les épidémies hivernales sont
arrivées et les services de réanimation
pédiatrique sont à nouveau saturés des
enfants ont été transférés hors région
avec tous les risques que cela comporte
aggravation de l'état de santé
conséquences psychique et somatiques à
plus long terme les soins non urgence
sont reportés les soignants sont
contraints de prévoir des sorties
prématurées d'hospitalisation ou de
renvoyer des adolescents des tresses
psychologiques chez eux le constat est
sans appel le manque de moyens et
surtout le manque de personnel entraîne
entraînant des conditions de travail
dégradé pour les professionnels qui ne
peuvent plus assurer correctement leur
mission en réponse ce dimanche le
gouvernement a annoncé un plan d'action
immédiat qui comprend l'activation de
plan blanc dans les territoires les plus
touchés ces plans déclenchés tous les
ans depuis 2020 ne peuvent plus être une
solution pérenne le plan d'action du
gouvernement comprend une aide de 150
millions d'euros pour les services
hospitaliers sous tension c'est
insuffisant la politique des pansements
ne tient plus comme nous le répétons
nous avons besoin d'investissement
massifs pour redonner de l'attractivité
et du sens au métier du soin pour faire
à nouveau primer la logique des besoins
humains et sanitaires sur la logique
comptable ce n'est pas ce qui a permis
le Ségur et ce n'est pas non plus que
prévoit le projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale pour 2023 alors
Monsieur le Ministre comment
comptez-vous répondre à cette situation
et quand allez-vous engager une réforme
profonde et globale de notre système de
soins je vous remercie je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur François Braun
ministre de la Santé de la prévention
madame la Présidente et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée Chantal
Jourdan personne ici je pense ne peut
prétendre que je ne connais pas des
problèmes de l'hôpital et à l'hôpital
les problèmes de la pédiatrie pour
preuve s'il en fallait dès que je suis
arrivé ce gouvernement sous l'impulsion
de la première ministre a mis en place
des mesures pour nous permettre
globalement de passer l'été dans une
situation déjà critique
cette épidémie de bronchiolite précoce
et pour laquelle je rencontre depuis 15
jours à plusieurs reprises les
professionnels du monde de la pédiatrie
arrivent sur un hôpital à bout de
souffle je l'ai déjà dit aussi cet
hôpital est à bout de souffle suite à
des décennies jusqu'en 2017 de politique
comptable
qui a étranglé progressivement
financièrement l’hôpital et dont les
budgets ont d'ailleurs été votés dans
cette assemblée à plusieurs reprises
il y a bien sûr dans cette situation des
actions à prendre des actions en urgence
et des actions à plus long terme vous
l'avez dit prendre des actions aux
urgences c'est libérer des initiatives
libérer des initiatives c'est aider les
services en crise et malheureusement pas
que les services de pédiatrie et puis à
plus long terme des enjeux nationaux là
aussi dans le cadre du CNR comme les
enjeux territoriaux qui vont nous
permettre de refonder structurellement
la filière de la pédiatrie est plus
globalement la prise en charge de la
santé de l'enfant
alors en urgence je l'ai dit les plans
blancs vous en parlez c'est pas une
mauvaise solution ça fonctionne mais
certes c'est un pansement
des conseils à donner aux parents parce
que aussi peuvent nous aider les gestes
barrières pour éviter la contamination
des enfants l'appel du 15 plutôt que de
se rendre systématiquement dans les
urgences les transferts vous en
parlaient mais les transferts c'est pour
mieux prendre en charge les enfants
c'est sûrement pas pour dégrader leurs
qualités de prise en charge et puis 150
millions de d'euros qui ont mises en
place pour répondre financièrement aux
difficultés immédiates et renforcer les
services enfin à plus long terme comme
je l'ai annoncé les assises de la
pédiatrie au printemps nous permettront
de voir avec les professionnels comment
restructurer l'ensemble de ce secteur
merci pour Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Bryan Masson pour
le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le garde des sceaux
pas un jour ne se passe sans qu'une
atrocité ne soit commise sur le
territoire national pas un jour ne se
passe sans que les défaillances de votre
politique ne soient pointés du doigt
quoi que vous disiez l'insécurité est
grandissante dans mon département des
Alpes-Maritimes le procureur de la
République de Nice a déclaré être très
inquiet de l'évolution des violences et
de leur particulière gravité à Angers il
y a quelques jours un violeur déjà
condamné et libéré avant le terme de sa
peine à tenté à nouveau de violer une
jeune femme à Grenoble ou un homme déjà
condamné pour avoir tué sur des
policiers à recommencer après un refus
d'obtempérer je pense à Marin tabasser
et rendu handicapé à vie en 2016 par une
racaille qui voit son agresseur libéré
bien avant le père le terme de sa peine
initiale c'est fait confirme l'en
sauvagement progressif de notre société
qui fait vivre des millions de Français
dans la peur de sortir dans la rue au
risque de se voir molester violenté
violée où tu es il confirme aussi la
réalité d'un laxisme judiciaire danger
il convient de rappeler que le dogme
visant à considérer que la fermeté des
peines favorise la récidive est une
aberration concernant la justice de
notre pays tous les voyants sont au
rouge surpopulation carcérale laxisme
judiciaire sur représentation des
étrangers en prison tous ces éléments
qui prouvent que votre politique est
inefficace vous avez déclaré il y a
quelques jours que les élus du
rassemblement national étaient des
extrémistes et que vous aviez des
comptes à régler avec eux vous n'avez
décidément honte de rien parce que
Monsieur le Ministre à l'inverse de vous
les membres de cet assemblée ont été
élus démocratiquement par les Français
et que de ce fait c'est vous qui avez
des comptes à nous rendre et pas
l'inverse
alors ma question est la suivante
monsieur le ministre quand allez-vous
cesser d'être aveuglé par votre
dogmatisme dangereux et enfin donner les
instructions nécessaires au parquet pour
en finir avec ce laxisme
je vous remercie
[Musique]
la parole est à monsieur Éric
Dupond-Moretti garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice
madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés monsieur
le député au fond vous tournez toujours
autour du même thème toujours
laxisme de la justice
voilà les chiffres puisque les mots ne
vous conviennent pas nous sommes passés
en 15 ans en matière correctionnelle de
6 mois à 9 mois d'emprisonnement ferme
nous sommes passés en matière criminelle
et je vous rappelle que en matière
criminelle ce sont nos compatriotes qui
rendent la justice nous sommes passés de
14 à 16 ans voilà la réalité vous n'en
voulez pas au fond vous faites un peu
comme sur certains plateaux de chaîne
continue vous avez une présentation de
la justice qui est fait diversiaire ce
que vous n'entendez pas c'est que
naturellement la rémission des crimes
même si par malheur vous veniez au
pouvoir personne ne peut y croire je ne
donne pas une semaine si vous étiez au
pouvoir sans que vous ayez à connaître
les crimes les infractions elles sont
consubstantielles à notre humanité ça ne
signifie pas qu'il failli être fataliste
je demande au parquet d'être extrêmement
sévère vous avez je l'ai déjà dit la
matraque magique vous répétez la même
chose au fond il flotte dans notre
époque un parfum qui n'a pas le goût
sucré des alizés mesdames et messieurs
les députés du rassemblement national
mais il a l'odeur nauséabonde
1938 voilà ce que vous nous faites
merci
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
Masson pour 9 secondes merci madame la
Présidente je modifie ma question
contenue de vos échecs monsieur le
ministre quand comptez-vous enfin
démissionner
la parole
la parole est au président marchand
jelly pour le groupe horizon
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues comme
l'a fait notre collègue Jourdan à
l'instant je voudrais partager avec
l'Assemblée l'inquiétude de nos
concitoyens professionnels de santé des
jeunes parents sur la crise que traverse
nos services de pédiatrie depuis
quelques jours la situation est comme
chacun le sait tendu ce qui ne va pas
sans nous rappeler ce que nous avions
vécu cet été les seuils d'alerte
épidémique de la bronchiolite chez les
moines de 2 ans ont été dépassés
précocément et ce dans pratiquement
toutes les régions le nombre d'enfants
hospitalisés a bondit de 50% en une
semaine la situation est arrivée à son
paroxysme en Île-de-France ou très
enfant dû être transféré hors de la
région faute de place dans les lits avec
tout ce que cela implique pour les
familles
vendredi 4000 professionnels de la
pédiatrie ont alerté par lettre ouverte
le président de la République sur la
situation de saturation et le
débordement des services dans un hôpital
public encore touché de plein fouet par
la crise sanitaire liée à la covid 2019
nous le savons des lits restent fermés
faute de blouse blanche et tous les ans
cette crise récurrente nous rappelle la
particulière fragilité de la situation
de la pédiatrie le gouvernement a
répondu présent pour répondre à
l'urgence pour traverser ce pic
épidémique et venir au secours notre
médecine pédiatrique sur le long terme
le groupe que je préside salue la
réponse rapide qui a été faite et les
150 millions d'euros qui ont été ainsi
débloqués pour faire face à cette
période hivernale et assurer des
renforts de personnels première étape
nécessaire pour traverser cette crise la
médecine de ville sera également
mobilisée et viendra prêter ma forte à
l'hôpital pour que tous les enfants
puissent être prises en charge nous
réaffirmons de la volonté de notre
groupe de garantir un modèle d'hôpital
public auquel les Français sont attachés
assurés à nos enfants les soins de
qualité pour tous sur ce point je me
félicite à personnel de l'ouverture
prochaine de nouvelles hôpital dans ma
ville d'Ajaccio madame la Première
ministre pourriez-vous nous indiquer
l'évolution de l'épidémie et si d'autres
transferts sont à prévoir d'autre part
pourriez-vous préciser quel sera
l'utilisation prévisionnelle de cette
enveloppe et comment sera-t-elle à louer
aux acteurs pédiatriques je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première ministre vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
Président Laurent Marc Angeli alors vous
l'avez souligné cette année l'épidémie
de bronchiolite s'est déclaré plutôt que
d'habitude et elle atteint des niveaux
exceptionnels pour un mois d'octobre la
situation varie naturellement selon les
régions mais elle est particulièrement
critique en Île-de-France
une fois de plus
cette épidémie met sous tension notre
hôpital et je veux avec vous rendre
hommage à nos soignants qui sont à
nouveau très mobilisés pour prendre en
charge les patients
et je pense aussi aux familles inquiète
pour la prise en charge de leur enfant
alors monsieur le Président Marc Angeli
mon gouvernement a réagi et pris les
mesures qui s'imposent depuis plusieurs
semaines le ministre de la Santé
François Braun a rencontré les
représentants de la pédiatrie il a
encore fait la semaine dernière pour
travailler avec eux sur des réponses à
court terme vous l'avez dit nous avons
développé débloqué une enveloppe
exceptionnelle de 150 millions d'euros
pourraient aider et soutenir les
services en tension notamment les
services pédiatriques cette enveloppe
sera mobilisée en fonction des
spécialités et des territoires et elle
doit permettre de débloquer des moyens
pour faire face aux surcharges dans les
services concernés que ce soit en
pédiatrie ou aux urgences nous avons par
ailleurs prolongé l'essentiel des
mesures du plan d'urgence de cet été en
particulier nous voulons intensifier les
coopérations entre
et la médecine de ville pour que les
enfants puissent avoir accès plus
facilement un médecin généraliste ou un
pédiatre et puis je veux aussi inviter
les familles à appeler le 15 avant de se
rendre aux urgences c'est l'assurance
d'être bien conseillé et orienté et puis
nous avons lancé une campagne de
prévention autour des bons gestes pour
limiter la propagation de l'épidémie de
bronchiolite mais au-delà des mesures
d'urgence mon gouvernement travaille
pour répondre au défi structurel que
connaît la pédiatrie c'est le sens des
Assises de la pédiatrie que nous voulons
tenir au printemps prochain toutes les
questions seront abordées collectivement
pour penser l'avenir de la discipline
assurer l'attractivité des métiers et
prendre les décisions qui s'imposent
mais monsieur le Président Marc Angeli
votre question fait co à une
préoccupation légitime et plus générale
de nos soignants sur leurs conditions de
travail et des Français sur leur santé
nous leur devons des réponses des et des
résultats au moment où nous examinons un
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale qui traduit une hausse
des moyens de 43 milliards d'euros par
rapport à 2019 avant l'épidémie de covid
au moment où nous examinons un projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale qui agit pour l'attractivité des
métiers qui financent les
revalorisations salariales les
investissements du Ségur de la santé au
moment où des moyens exceptionnels sont
proposés la majorité je n'en doute pas
le gouvernement sont prêts à la
discussion alors agissons ensemble pour
la santé des Français je vous remercie
merci madame la Première ministre la
parole est à Madame Elise le boucher
pour le groupe la France insoumise merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de la santé la prévention ce
week-end plus de 6500 soignants et des
associations de patientes adressé une
tribune au président de la République
pour dénoncer l'abandon par le
gouvernement de l'hôpital public et de
la médecine pédiatrie après deux
semaines d'épidémie hivernale pourtant
habituel et prévisible les services de
règne animation pédiatriques sont
partout en France déjà saturé les soins
Dinant urgents sont reportés des enfants
dans la santé mentale et fragile sort
prématurément des enfants sont gardés
sur des brancards hospitalisés dans des
réanimations pour adultes ou même
transférer faute de place hors de leur
région pensez-vous qu'il est normal que
des enfants malades soient séparés
depuis de 100 km de leur famille
pouvez-vous imaginer leur détresse et
que dire de la perte de sens de leur
travail pour les professionnels face à
cette situation de crise vous nous
proposez monsieur le ministre un plan
blanc des heures supplémentaires
rémunérées des assises et ensuite quoi
un numéro vert
vous nous expliquez que la situation est
en lien avec les épidémies plutôt
pratique non la situation actuelle et le
résultat de plus de 20 années de
destructions méthodiques et planifiées
du service public de santé avec chaque
année un budget inférieur aux besoins
nous sommes passés en 20 ans selon l'OMS
du meilleur système de santé du monde à
la 15e place la mortalité infantile
augmente et l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé est inférieure à la moyenne
européenne quant aux soignants pourtant
passionnés par leur métier il quitte des
hôpitaux plus d'un tiers des Françaises
et des Français ont déjà renoncé à se
soigner en raison du coût de la santé
pourtant un droit fondamental conquis
par le Conseil National de la Résistance
avec la création de la Sécurité sociale
je vous souffle quelques solutions
recruter 100000 soignants titulariser
les contractuels revaloriser les
salaires reconnaître la pénibilité du
travail sortir du tout tarification à
l'acte reprendre la dette des hôpitaux
monsieur le ministre quand allez-vous
prendre vos responsabilités et
abandonner votre vision néolibérale
dangereuse et irresponsable quelles
actions comptez-vous prendre pour
résoudre la situation d'urgence des
services de pédiatrie et améliorer les
conditions de travail à l'accueil à
l'hôpital public ainsi que les
conditions d'accueil des patients merci
beaucoup ma chère collègue
la parole est à Monsieur François Brown
ministre de la Santé de la prévention
[Applaudissements]
madame la députée Lise le boucher madame
la Présidente pardon mesdames et
messieurs les députés je vous remercie
madame la députée de me rappeler mes
responsabilités ça fait 35 ans que je
les exerce auprès de pas sur malade dans
les urgences et je ne compte pas changer
de position aujourd'hui
les difficultés du système de santé ont
été rappelés je vous remercie de
partager le diagnostic que ce
gouvernement porte depuis plusieurs mois
voire même année et en particulier la
notion de perte de sens pour les
différents professionnels de santé vous
savez que
depuis le début de l'été j'ai engagé une
refondation du système de santé avec en
particulier ce conseil national de la
refondation que j'ai d'ailleurs lancé et
débuter dans votre département qui je
crois est la Sarthe et pour lequel nous
attendons des réponses non seulement
locales territoriales parce que là où
sont les problèmes là où sont les
solutions mais également au niveau
national sur des problèmes plus
structurels comme les assises ça a été
dit que nous allons faire autour de la
santé de l'enfant alors je vous entends
dans dans vos critiques et je vais me
permettre quelques petites corrections
la première le numéro vert dont vous
parlez il existe ça s'appelle le 15
c'est le SAMU ça vous permet d'avoir un
médecin au téléphone en quelques minutes
partout vous êtes
concernant les transferts que vous avez
l'habitude de montrer comme une
dégradation de la prise en charge des
enfants c'est au contraire garantir aux
enfants comme aux adultes d'ailleurs une
meilleure prise en charge en les mettant
dans le meilleur endroit pour les
prendre nous avons réalisé plus de 600
transferts pendant cette crise covid
avec des patients dont l'état de santé
est meilleur que ceux qui sont restés
dans des services saturés c'est donc une
réponse extrêmement positive face à
cette situation d'urgence
aux familles je veux redire faites le 15
ne vous précipitez pas vers les services
d'urgence nous allons prendre en charge
l'ensemble des patients bien entendus
aux professionnels de la pédiatrie je
veux préciser que je les ai rencontrés
je les ai entendus je partage leurs
inquiétudes et nous mettons tout en
place pour refonder là aussi ces
filières de pédiatrie merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre
[Musique]
la parole est à Madame Maud petit pour
le groupe démocrate
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de la Santé le 17 octobre
dernier se tenait la Journée mondiale de
contre la douleur je veux rappeler ici
qu'il y a des mots invisibles et
quotidiens qui détruisent des vies je
souhaite porter aujourd'hui la voix de
ceux qui subissent les affres des
douleurs chroniques et leur dire qu'ils
ne sont pas seuls que leur combat et le
nôtre les causes de la douleur chronique
sont multiples suite d'une opération
chirurgicale d'un traitement médical et
fait d'une maladie en résulte une
souffrance quotidienne invalidante
parfois silencieuse souvent la douleur
chronique concerne près de 12 millions
de nos compatriotes 20% de notre
population elle touche n'importe lequel
d'entre nous à tous les âges source de
handicap d'isolement social de
souffrance psychologique mais aussi
d'inactivité d'absentéisme professionnel
il en résulte un phénomène sociétal en
augmentation à prendre en compte la loi
du 4 mars 2002 relative au droit des
malades et à la qualité du le système de
santé reconnaît la prise en charge et le
soulagement de la douleur comme des
droits fondamentaux du patient je vous
interroge ainsi sur la pérennisation des
structures douleurs chroniques qui
prennent en charge des patients
douloureux complexes sur le territoire
métropolitain et ultramarin ce
dispositif unique en Europe constitue un
maillon essentiel du parcours de soins
et participe à la diminution de
l'errance diagnostic et thérapeutique
après trois plans nationaux de lutte
contre la douleur cependant le modèle
s'essouffle la couverture territoriale
était hétérogène et fragile les nombreux
départs à la retraite non remplacé
l'offre actuelle couvre seulement 1,4%
des patients elle ne couvre pas les
besoins des patients douloureux les plus
complexes les sociétés savantes sont
dans l'attente de la publication par la
HAS des recommandations relatives au
parcours des soins du patient douloureux
elles appellent à plusieurs mesures pour
pérenniser et démultiplier ce modèle de
prise en charge monsieur le ministre
quel est donc la feuille de route du
gouvernement pour pérenniser ses Stru et
assurer un accès effectif à une prise en
charge de qualité des patients
douloureux dans notre pays je vous
remercie beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur François Braun
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée maudit vous
avez raison de souligner l'importance de
ce phénomène de la douleur chronique
trop de nos concitoyens souffrent on
évalue à 12 millions effectivement et si
on les spécialistes de la douleur qui le
disent d'une douleur chronique avec un
traitement qui est insuffisamment adapté
trop peu sont pris ensemble au sein des
centres de prise en charge de la douleur
chronique pourtant 242 centre existe sur
le territoire national aujourd'hui c'est
un enjeu de santé publique avec des
conséquences personnelles des
conséquences familiales des conséquences
professionnelles aussi et s'il y a un
exemple qui nous montre bien cette
problématique de douleur chronique tout
au long de la vie c'est bien la
drépanocytose mais je pense nous aurons
l'occasion peut-être demain d'en
reparler dans le cadre des politiques de
prévention
la douleur chronique ne doit pas être
prise en charge uniquement dans les
centres de santé ça fait partie un
parcours de soins et ce parcours de
soins il concerne aussi les médecins
généralistes traitants qui restent le
premier recours de la prise en charge de
cette douleur les centres de santé
arrivant plutôt en second recours avec
des prises en charge plus
riprofessionnelles et d'ailleurs je me
souligner ici l'engagement de ses
professionnels mais aussi la mise en
place d'études très spécifiques sur des
techniques pas forcément médicamenteuses
de prise en charge de la douleur et qui
sont particulièrement efficaces je pense
par exemple ici aux techniques d'hypnose
médicale
sur ce parcours nous avons saisi la
Haute Autorité de Santé en novembre 2022
et j'attends ses conclusions sur le
parcours tout début 2023
parallèlement nous relançons la
labellisation qui doit avoir lieu tous
les trois ans pour ces centres et fin de
cette année nous aurons les chiffres de
labellisation avec une volonté
d'intégrer beaucoup plus la médecine de
ville et ses centres spécialités vous
l'avez dit nous avons un maillage qui
est exceptionnel en Europe en plus de
ces 24200 il y a 30 centres avancées
pour aller au plus près de nos
concitoyens qui sont loin éventuellement
de ces villes pour le renforcer deux
points un appel à manifestation
d'enterrer sur des protocoles de
coopération entre infirmiers et médecins
sous la supervision médicale qui est
lancée et puis la mise en place à partir
de l'année prochaine de postes
d'assistant spécialiste de la douleur 20
postes par an merci
la parole est à Monsieur Patrick Etel
pour le groupe les républicains
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre entre Paris et Berlin rien ne
va plus le Conseil des ministres
franco-allemand normalement prévu demain
vient d'être reporté cinédié suite à des
divergences importantes entre nos deux
pays les contentieux sont désormais
nombreux l'Allemagne bloque deux
importants projets industriels en
matière de défense le projet d'avion et
le projet de char l'Allemagne verrouille
au niveau européen le contrôle des
exportations d'armement l'Allemagne
vient de choisir un bouclier
anti-missiles qui tourne le dos à la
France l'Allemagne vient d'investir seul
200 milliards d'euros pour ces
entreprises et ses ménages pour faire
face au prix de l'énergie et nous dit
que si nous avions été budgétairement
plus vertueux nous pourrions faire de
même l'Allemagne refuse également la
modification du mode de calcul du prix
de l'énergie à l'échelle européenne qui
pourtant serait tellement importante
pour la France madame la Première
ministre vous vous contentez de parler
de souveraineté là où le chancelier
Scholl s’exerce que comptez-vous faire
désormais pour défendre les intérêts de
la France je vous remercie je vous
remercie
[Musique]
merci merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur et Madame
les députés et Monsieur les députés
Patrick herzel nous avons décidé
ensemble non pas de annuler mais de
reporter ce conseil des ministres
franco-allemand qui comme vous le savez
était prévu le 26 octobre il y a
plusieurs raisons à cela je vais
commencer par la première qui est très
simple c'est que nous voulions un
conseil des ministres plein et que
certains ministres Allemands n'étaient
pas disponibles notamment la ministre
des Affaires étrangères ce qui vous
conviendrait dans la période de guerre
dans laquelle nous vivons est un peu
embêtant la deuxième c'est sur le fond
il vous l'avez évoqué un monsieur le
député d'abord il y a beaucoup de
substances oui oui je le vois et si j'ai
une substance la défense vous en avez
parlé l'énergie vous n'en avez pas parlé
l'économie l'Allemagne a mis 200
milliards sur la table comme le ministre
Bruno Le Maire l'a dit plusieurs fois
nous avons plus de 100 milliards il
s'agit là de coordonner nos efforts et
de coordonner aussi nos efforts en
matière industrielle de défense et
d'énergie nous sommes sur la substances
et pas sur la forme ces sujets sont
compliqués et d'autant plus que
l'Allemagne a à faire à une coalition
tripartite et comme le monde parfois
l'assemblée négocié à trois parties
c'est difficile voilà le couple
franco-allemand il n'est pas du tout
affaibli au contraire il marche très
bien d'ailleurs quand il est trop fort
il inquiète et quand il n'est pas assez
fort il inquiète encore merci beaucoup
je vous remercie madame la ministre
monsieur Hetzel
merci beaucoup à un Président je suis
très étonné par votre réponse évidemment
vous nous dites que tout irait bien et
en réalité vous le savez et vous le
savez précisément ce sont les Allemands
qui n'ont pas donné suite à un certain
nombre de demandes formulées tout
simplement parce que la position de la
France aujourd'hui est affaiblie elle
est affaiblie parce que Monsieur Macron
évidemment est arrivé à un moment donné
en disant vous allez voir ce que vous
allez voir et bien 5 ans après nous
voyons nous voyons que en réalité dans
cette relation d'ailleurs plus qu'un
couple cette relation franco-allemande
elle est désormais asymétrique parce que
les Allemands ont été vertueux ils ont
été capables évidemment de faire en
sorte que d'un point de vue budgétaire
aujourd'hui ils sont capables de faire
un certain nombre de choses et on le
voit bien la faiblesse de la France est
énorme et nous vous le devons
effectivement et la question
fondamentale c'est celle aujourd'hui de
l'énergie sur la question énergétique
que répondez-vous à nos concitoyens
lorsque nous souhaitons désormais à la
fois nos concitoyens et nos entreprises
qu'est-ce que vous leur dites pour que
nous puissions avoir des nouveaux tarif
évidemment en matière énergétique rien
merci monsieur le député
la parole est à Monsieur Sacha Ollier
pour le groupe Renaissance merci madame
la Présidente ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'Intérieur et des outre-mer
et avant de nous interroger monsieur le
ministre je vais rendre hommage aux
gendarmes qui a perdu la vie cette nuit
dans l'heure ainsi qu'à ses camarades
blessés
monsieur le ministre des quartiers
populaires de Poitiers au territoire
d'outre-mer comme la Guyane ou nous
étions il y a quelques semaines toute la
France parle de sécurité le droit à la
tranquillité de nos concitoyens est
absolu c'est un acquis que nous devons
charmant défendre pourtant beaucoup de
nos concitoyens disent leurs sentiments
de vivre dans une société plus violente
les Français décrivent une menace
protéiforme agression physique dans la
rue trafic de drogue vandalisme
harcèlement ou agression sexuelle nous
voulons être à la hauteur de leurs
attentes et de leurs exigences monsieur
le ministre il y a deux ans devant la
commission des lois vous aviez établi la
liste des 7 Pécheux péchés capitaux de
la police vous aviez dit ce qu'il
marchait pas ce que nous devions
corriger le manque de formation le
manque d'encadrement le manque de moyens
humains et matériel l'encadrement du
recours à la vidéo le renforcement de la
confiance dans nos inspections des
citoyens dans leur police et
l'amélioration de la relation entre
policiers justice alors ma première
question est la suivante pourquoi la loi
d'orientation et du programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur répond à ces
enjeux vous avez commencé à déployer les
8500 policiers gendarmes supplémentaires
qui s'ajoutent aux 10000 recrutés formés
durant le dernier quinquennat 300
policiers en plus à Marseille 160 CRS et
gendarmes supplémentaires à Lille autant
à Montpellier à Béziers 70 à Nantes
mesurez-vous déjà les résultats de ce
déploiement sur le refus de la
délinquance sur le délémentairement des
réseaux en terme de sécurité ne
concitoyens nous impose une obligation
de résultats le projet examiner la
semaine prochaine par l'Assemblée
prévoit 15 milliards d'euros déployés
sur les cinq prochaines années dont la
moitié consacrée à la cybers criminalité
à entendre l'orateur du groupe
socialiste Sénat la demande de sécurité
exprimée par nos concitoyens les a
convaincus de voter en faveur de ce
texte et de moyens supplémentaires
alloués à nos forces de sécurité voici
donc ma dernière question monsieur le
ministre comment convaincre nos
collègues députés LR et socialistes de
suivre le vote des sénateur de leur
groupe
merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois permettait moi aussi d'avoir un
mot pour le gendarme décédé cette nuit
dans l'Eure pour ses camarades essaient
de moins grièvement ce gendarme et veuf
ça veuve pardon désormais à 4 enfants
qu'elle va élever je l'espère en lien
direct avec l'État qui soit au
rendez-vous et j'irai présenté présider
à ces obsèques et on pense évidemment à
tous les policiers gendarmes qui meurent
en opération en mission et en service
aujourd'hui
merci
merci pour nos forces de l'ordre c'est
le Président c'est justement avec la
pensée que la mort rencontre
malheureusement les policiers légendes
pour nous protéger que la première
ministre est présente de la République
en arbitré une augmentation de 15
milliards d'euros sur les 5 ans qui
viennent du ministère de l'intérieur
avec une augmentation d'effectifs vous
l'avez dit 8500 supplémentaires mais
également des moyens hors du commun pour
lutter contre les nouvelles menaces je
pense à la menace cyber qui touche ici
et maintenant et demain de plus encore
plus nos concitoyens nos collectivités
locales nos hôpitaux nos entreprises
mais également les nouveaux désordre
public et ils sont extrêmement nombreux
on les a ces derniers mois ces dernières
années mais bien sûr évidemment la lutte
contre le terrorisme et toute forme de
délinquance protéiforme désormais assez
internationale et de plus en plus
technologique nous devons sur le modèle
de la programmation militaire dire
pendant 5 ans ce que nous voulons faire
pour le ministère de l'Intérieur pour
les femmes et les hommes qui le servent
pour renforcer la sécurité de nos
concitoyens en lien bien sûr avec le
ministère de la Justice qui connaît
parallèlement une loi de programmation
d'augmentation de ces crédits vous
demandez comment nous avons fait pour
qu'au Senna la quasi uneanimité
politique se retrouve sur un texte du
ministère de l'Intérieur pour voter ses
augmentations ses créations de 200
brigades partout dans vos territoires
ces unités de force mobile
supplémentaires et ces effectifs en plus
dans vos commissariats et bien nous
sommes allés vers une question
compliquée avec des idées simples
monsieur le Président celui de discuter
et moi dans quelques jours nous serons
en commission des lois c'est avec le
même esprit de concorde et d'ouverture
de la part du gouvernement quelle que
soit les groupes politiques que nous
discuterons et j'espère que nous
trouverons ici la même con pour que ce
soit pas un sujet poéticien mais un
sujet de soutien des policiers et des
gendarmes
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Madame Yaël ménage pour
le groupe rassemblement national merci
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre le
maire et porte sur l'impact de la crise
énergétique sur le secteur agricole et
ses emplois nous sommes comptables de
l'inaction du gouvernement et nous
interrogeons sur votre capacité à
admettre le principe de réalité au-delà
de l'idéologie à l'ignorance des métiers
agricoles s'ajoutent votre mépris du
réel comme des enfants gâtés qui
refusent de manger des endives vous vous
tenez là passif résolu à ignorer votre
assiette et bien je vais vous en servir
moi des endives nous endiviez dans les
hauts de France représente plus de 4000
emplois qui vont mettre la clé sur la
sous la porte si vous ne prenez pas
immédiatement des mesures leurs factures
d'électricité ont augmenté de 350%, ils
sont l'avant-garde de tous les autres
exploitants agricoles qui dépendent de
la chaîne du froid il symbolise
l'autonomie alimentaire de la nation
à défaut de réagir vous proposez en fait
les traitements le délestage partiel
l'effacement sélectif de la souveraineté
nationale car vous placez l'intérêt des
Français après celui de l'Europe quand
la souveraineté a été à ce point
marchandée conditionné par autre chose
qu'un peuple le peuple demande en fin de
compte la protection qu'exige son
autodétermination c'est parce que nous
sommes libres que nous sommes souverains
la liberté est souveraineté ne font
qu'un aujourd'hui le peuple vous dit ici
dans l'hémicycle que si vous ne le
protégez pas vous aurez sur vos épaules
tout le poids de la ruine de notre pays
et sa trahison à défaut de vous être
conduit en femme et en homme d'État il
vous restera la reconversion selon votre
carnet d'adresses vous n'avez pas
vraiment le luxe au fond de refuser la
moindre poignée de main des mesures de
protection s'impose mais
qu'attendez-vous nous avons sacrifié
notre souveraineté énergétique en
entrant dans le marché européen de
l'énergie à présent celui-ci détruit
notre souveraineté alimentaire alors ça
s'arrête où la grande braderie nationale
alors je vous pose la question monsieur
le ministre allez-vous enfin protéger
les Français et sortir du marché
européen de l'énergie comme le propose
Marine Le Pen depuis longtemps
je vous remercie la parole
la parole est à Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
ministre de l'Économie des Finances de
la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique
merci blabla Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
ménage
je regrette que vous ayez choisi
l'agression du ministre plutôt que la
défense des 3500 producteurs d'endives
je vous rappellerai que je suis minis
économies des finances mais j'ai été
trois ans ministre de l'Agriculture et
j'ai toujours défendu l'agriculture
française et les paysans français et je
vais vous faire une confidence madame
ménage mes enfants et moi-même nous
adorons les endives donc nous ferons un
plaisir de défendre les endiviers en
prenant des mesures concrètes immédiates
plus efficaces que celles que vous
proposez nous allons mettre en place une
garantie électricité qui va permettre à
la demande de la première ministre de
mieux protéger l'ensemble des
producteurs agricoles l'ensemble des PME
l'ensemble des TPE les boulangers
aujourd'hui qui ne sont pas suffisamment
protégés par les mesures qui sont
existantes nous vous apportons la
certitude que toutes les PME tous les
TPE endiguier comme boulanger
agriculteurs comme commerçants seront
protégés contre l'augmentation des prix
de l'électricité par la mise en place de
cette garantie énergie nous avons
également obtenu de la part de la
Commission européenne une simpl
drastique après trois semaines de
négociation du bouclier sur le gaz et du
guichet sur le gaz désormais toute
entreprise qui aura eu 150%
d'augmentation et non parfois deux sur
sa facture sera éligible à ce guichet
sur le gaz tout entreprises qui aura une
forte augmentation de la fin 2022 sera
éligible à ce guichet sur le gaz tout
entreprises qui rencontre des
difficultés pour avoir des aides qui ne
seront pas de deux 25 ou 50 millions
d'euros mais 4 50 ou 100 millions
d'euros nous avons travaillé à la
protection de nos entreprises et nous
consacrerons 10 milliards d'euros à la
protection des entreprises françaises
contre l'augmentation des prix du gaz
d'électricité nous préférons toujours
aux grands discours de rassemblement
national les décisions et la réalité de
cette majorité merci monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Thomas porte le
groupe la France insoumise monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
nombre de nos compatriotes ont voté ce
jour pour moi non pour soutenir les
idées que je porte mais pour faire
barrage à celle de l'extrême droite
voilà les mots prononcés par un Emmanuel
Macron au soir du second tour des
élections présidentielles quel barrage
en réalité il n'a jamais existé pire il
s'est transformé en marche pied commenté
point et cette tâche brune que
représente les 89 députés du
rassemblement national que votre
majorité a fait lire avec Jupiter les
prétendudiques sont transformés en pont
de la réhabilitation de Pétain à la loi
sur le séparatisme en passant par votre
chasse du soi-disant islamo gauchisme
vous n'avez cessé d'accumuler les gages
s'il vous plaît
un jeu dangereux alors que les violences
de l'ultra-droit se multiplient partout
dans le pays quand on souffle sur des
braises ardentes les conséquences
peuvent devenir dramatiques le 19 mars
dernier Monsieur le Ministre un joueur
de rugby Frédéric au Martin a rembouru a
été assassiné en plein Paris par des
militants d'extrême droite vous avez été
silencieux
la semaine dernière ce sont des
royalistes d'actions françaises qui ont
envahi la mairie de Stains et menacer
son maire asyn Taibi là aussi silence de
votre part
ce week-end une nouvelle étape a été
franchie des groupuscules néonazis
issus de la dissolution de génération
identitaire on manifesté à Rennes Lyon
et Paris les amis de l'extrême droite en
poussant en écrire raciste silence de
votre part monsieur le ministre
où est le 3 10 ans rempart Emmanuel
Macron un rempart de pacotille qui n'a
rien trouvé de mieux que de se vautrer
en Italie pour saluer la dirigeante
fasciste Giuseppe Meloni c'est une tâche
pour notre République alors monsieur le
ministre à quel moment allez vous tester
d'être complaisant avec l'extrême droite
quand allez-vous combattre ces
groupuscules mais en Asie
la parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
je remercie
d'écoute attends je remercie s'il vous
plaît seul monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur à la parole
merci madame la Présidente
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député porte je propose pour
être très cohérent que lorsqu'on dénonce
extrême droite on n'accepte pas ses
votes
je propose le seul député pour qu'on
soit cohérent que Monsieur Mélenchon de
disparu turby qu'il était heureux qu'à
quelques voix près de sa droite vous
fassiez tomber le gouvernement
la vérité monsieur le député c'est que
vous vivez grâce à l'opposition est
extrême droite nous avons tous vu nous
qui sommes présentés aux élections
législatives à quel point au second tour
vous n'avez pas appelé à faire barrage à
l'extrême droite
monsieur le député
nous qui avons nous qui avons dissous
nous qui avons dissous génération
identitaire je vous propose que pour
manger avec le diable il faut prendre
une grande cuillère
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre il
vous reste 6 secondes
personne n'a oublié que Emmanuel Macron
a été élu avec les voix du rassemblement
national et par défaut
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre
puisqu'il me reste 46 secondes monsieur
le député vous auriez pu vous engager
est-ce que jamais vos voix ne se mêlent
à celle de l'extrême droite mais vous
avez préféré faire de la politique la
vérité c'est que tout le monde voit que
vous ne cherchez que le chaos que vous
ne souhaitez pas le bien-être des
Français parce que vous vivez du
problème des gens et la vérité monsieur
le député c'est que sur les marchés vos
militants se retrouvent pour nous battre
et heureusement que nous sommes là pour
vous dire que c'est vous qui travaillez
avec Madame Le Pen
merci monsieur le ministre
alors nous allons continuer la séance
des questions gouvernement et je compte
sur vous pour écouter attentivement la
prochaine question posée par Monsieur
virer pour le goproblicain
merci merci madame la Présidente
effectivement en effectivement sérénité
je voudrais interroger madame la
Première ministre sur une préoccupation
majeure des Français semaines et
semaines madame la Première ministre
notre pays sur laborieusement de la
pénurie de carburant que les Français
vivent depuis plusieurs semaines et
aujourd'hui encore une station-service
sur 5 reste impactée par les difficultés
d'approvisionnement et les Français
faut-il le reconnaître subissent la
lenteur de réaction du gouvernement face
au blocage des raffineries et une
nouvelle difficulté se présente
aujourd'hui en cette sortie de crise
c'est celle du prix des carburants avec
des hausses et parfois des plis
exorbitants vous le savez je le répète
dans beaucoup de territoires en France
le recours à la voiture est usuel est
nécessaire et même incontournable pour
des actusuels de la vie amener ses
enfants à l'école les amener leur
activité sportive et culturelle aller
voir des proches faire ses courses elle
est tout autant pour un certain nombre
de professions la voiture est un outil
de travail qui ne serait être remplacé
les aides à domicile les le premier les
travailleurs indépendants ou tout
simplement les salariés
sans être financière du gouvernement le
carburant peut être inaccessible pour
toutes ces personnes dès juillet à
l'occasion de l'examen du projet de loi
de finance rectificative pour 2022 le
travail constructif des députés les
républicains et permis d'obtenir une
aide au carburant pour les Français mais
c'était va disparaître définitivement au
1er janvier 2023 comme la confirmé
madame la ministre de la transition
énergétique dimanche dernier et les
français s'inquiètent de cette situation
et de la hausse du prix des carburants
alors que les prix de l'énergie sont
parallèles déjà inabordables vous avez
eu des nouvelles propositions des
députés les républicains pour
redonnerard d'achat dans le cadre
notamment des débats budgétaires
l'activation du 49 3 nous a pas permis
de valider ces mesures mais nous avions
une mesure qui aurait permis de limiter
la hausse du prix du carburant c'est
celle de baisser la taxe sur la TICPE
c'est dommage que vous ne l'ayez pas
reprises face à ces risques madame la
Première ministre quelle mesure le
gouvernement entendu prendre pour faire
baisser durablement le prix des
carburants
je vous remercie la parole est à
monsieur Clément bonne ministre des
Transports
c'est aussi agir en même temps sur
l'urgence et sur le pouvoir d'achat et
préparer pour tous et pour tous ceux qui
en ont besoin ont besoin de l'automobile
pour le quotidien des dispositifs
d'accompagnement de l'État merci
Monsieur le Ministre la parole est à
Madame Sandrine Lefort pour le groupe
Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires
Christophe Béchu l'heure est grave la
France se réchauffe vite trop vite
d'après les dernières projections nous
pourrions atteindre les + 3,8 degrés de
réchauffement climatique à horizon 2100
l'heure n'est pas seulement grave en
France elle est dramatique pour certains
pays de par le monde je pense aux États
insulaires aux États dont le faible
dénivelé les rangs extrêmement
vulnérables à la montée du niveau des
océans les climatologues nous le disent
la vulnérabilité climatique possède de
multiples facettes qui s'accumulent et
se multiplient à mesure que le
réchauffement progresse et que la
biodiversité sérode
loin de moi l'envie de faire du
sensationnalisme nul besoin de le faire
la crise sans précédent que nous vivons
ne nécessite nul exagération son spectre
nous menace et se fait déjà tangible
tangible car cet été la France a brûlé
tangible car cet été la surmortalité
liée aux canicules à répétition à
dépasser des records palpable car au
sein des ménages comme dans les
ministères les conséquences budgétaires
de cette crise sont préoccupantes être à
la hauteur de l'urgence écologique est
impératif est un impératif vital pour
l'État français pour le gouvernement et
pour la représentation nationale nous
devons montrer l'exemple et respecter
nos engagements monsieur le ministre le
gouvernement s'est engagé à planifier la
transition il s'en donne aujourd'hui les
moyens opérationnels via le lancement du
plan d'action France nations verte
le gouvernement s'en donne les moyens
budgétaires en augmentant de 4,5
milliards d'euros les dépenses
favorables à l'environnement dans le
budget pour 2023 monsieur le ministre ce
plan d'action est il à la hauteur pour
transformer en profondeur l'économie
française la France s'en donne-t-elle
également les moyens en réduisant les
dépenses défavorables à l'environnement
je vous remercie merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
Béchu ministre la transition écologique
et de la collision des territoires merci
madame la Présidente la première
ministre madame la députée Sandrine
Lefeuvre
vous avez posé un constat que nous
connaissons et qui quand on dézoom et
qu'on regarde à l'échelle mondiale
permet de mesurer à quel point le sommet
de charmelcher pour la COP 27 va être
important puisque les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre dans le monde non
seulement ne diminue pas mais il
continue de progresser un rapport de
l'ONU a même révélé qui nous avions sept
fois
en réserve des énergies fossiles 7 fois
plus que ce que nous sommes autorisés à
relâcher dans l'atmosphère pour ne pas
dépasser les deux degrés dont nous
parlons 3500 milliards de tonnes la
France fait partie des 20 pays qui ont
amorcé une baisse de leurs émissions de
gaz à effet de serre mais cette baisse
il faut qu'on l'intensifie et le 21
octobre dernier à la recyclerie
Elisabeth borne a lancé dans le cadre du
Conseil national de la refondation
climat et biodiversité les chantiers qui
vont permettre de finaliser cette
feuille de route pour la planification
écologique devant plusieurs dizaines de
parties prenantes se sont pas moins de
22 chantiers qui sont lancés avec les
associations avec les élus avec les
entreprises pour que dans six grandes
familles se déplacer se loger se nourrir
produire consommer préserver la
biodiversité nous puissions
calculer amplifier budgété les sommes
dont nous avons besoin pour tenir les
engagements climatiques de la France et
à ces 22 chantiers 7 chantiers
transversaux dans celui du financement
et de la fiscalité et celui de la
transition juste et solidaire sont
lancées une ambition être la première
nation à sortir des énergies fossiles
une date celle de cette planification
écologique un moyen une méthode avec un
calendrier et des budgets c'est l'enjeu
qu'elle nous appelons à la mobilisation
générale pour parvenir à ce gigantesque
défi merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Emeline kerbidi pour le
coup obligé de
[Applaudissements]
bonjour madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le garde des sceaux
monsieur le garde des sceaux il y a 6
jours une magistrate est morte en pleine
audience au tribunal de Nanterre
foudroyé par un malaise cardiaque qui
lui a été fatal une enquête est en cours
afin de déterminer si le surmenage et la
cause du décès néanmoins permettez-moi
de le rappeler quand on meurt sur son
lieu de travail ça n'est jamais anodin
les collègues de cette magistrate la
décrivent comme une professionnelle
acharnée très consciencieuse c'est
l'occasion ici pour moi de lui rendre
hommage
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre votre gouvernement
ne pouvait ignorer les conditions de
travail de cette magistrate en effet
quelques mois avant son décès les mêmes
magistrats et fonctionnaires du tribunal
de Nanterre voit-elle une motion
présentant une liste de 121 tâches
impossibles à les réaliser contenu du
manque de moyens ce décès intervient
dans un contexte de surmenage généralisé
dans la profession multiplication des
arrêts de travail burn out un mal-être
global qui a été jusqu'à pousser au
suicide une magistrat du tribunal de
Béthune en août 2021 le manque
d'effectif est criant cet après-midi
nous examinerons en commission le budget
justice seul 1500 postes de magistrats
sont prévus sur la totalité du
quinquennat 300 parents en moyenne alors
que les présidents de tribunaux en
demandent 1500 immédiatement vous le
savez nous sommes un des plus mauvais
élèves de l'Europe selon la Commission
européenne la France compte moins de 11
juges pour 100 000 habitants contre 24
en ce nouveau décès a-t-il permis à de
votre gouvernement de prendre conscience
de l'urgence de la situation pour mettre
en place un plan de recrutement dans la
magistrature je ne parle pas ici d'un
vaste job dating somme comme cela a été
fait pour recruter les professeurs dans
l'éducation nationale mais d'un
véritable plan Marshall de la
magistrature monsieur le ministre
combien de juges devront encore mourir
en poste pour prendre la mesure du
manque criant de moyen humain dans la
magistrature
je vous remercie la parole est à
monsieur Éric Dupont-Moretti garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice
ainsi donc madame la députée je serai
nous serions responsables de la mort de
cette femme de 44 ans
vous avez le droit de dire ce que vous
voulez vous êtes libre
s'agissant du suicide que vous avez
évoqué j'ai demandé une inspection
générale de la justice
je n'ai pas rendu public pour une raison
parce que cette jeune femme avait des
parents et que je ne souhaitais
absolument pas qu'un certain nombre de
choses soient dites j'ai préféré la
décence et ça n'est pas votre cas
mais
qu'il ne soit tout de même permis de
vous dire bien sûr
que nous sommes tous
extrêmement attristés par ce drame
d'abord la famille je me suis exprimé
auprès de la famille mais également
toute la communauté judiciaire et bien
sûr on l'imagine le tribunal de Nanterre
maintenant vous pouvez faire un
raccourci
un véritable raccourci madame entre la
mort de cette femme et ce que vous
appelez le manque de moyens mais je
voudrais vous dire vous l'avez rappelé
vous-même que des enquêtes sont en cours
une première enquête pour établir les
causes de la mort une deuxième comité
d'hygiène de sécurité des conditions de
travail cette enquête est ouverte et
nous serons attentifs aux résultats mais
ne nous donnez pas de leçon parce que
sous la gauche de 2012 à 2017 c'est à
peine 14 % d'augmentation du budget
depuis qu'Emmanuel Macron était lui
président de la République c'est plus de
44%. voyez-vous
et puis et puis et puis pour dire les
choses encore nous avions prévu dès le
mois de juin madame dès le mois de juin
la localisation de 5 de 5 nouveaux
postes de magistrat à Nanterre sans
compter les contractuels et puis il
reste bien sûr les États généraux et la
mise en place des promesses et des
engagements du Président de la
République ces promesses et ses
engagements seront tenus je veux enfin
vous dire que cet après-midi je
présenterai le budget 2023 et que
naturellement la question des moyens est
au cœur de ma réflexion au cœur de la
réflexion du gouvernement voilà ma
réponse madame
la parole est à Madame Sabrina c'est
bailli pour le groupe écologiste merci
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
mesdames et messieurs les ministres ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Intérieur
monsieur le ministre en Europe 64
personnes ont été arrêtées en lien avec
le terrorisme d'extrême droite en deux
ans dont près de la moitié rien qu'en
France c'est une préoccupation majeure
de nos services de renseignement le
terreau de leurs idées nous le
connaissons ce sont celles portées par
des groupes identitaires ou néonazis
monsieur le ministre le 8 octobre
dernier une quinzaine de militants de
l'Action française se sont introduits
par la force dans l'hôtel de ville de
Stains en Seine-Saint-Denis faisant
usage de fumigène et voici feront des
slogans racistes et xénophobes ce groupe
muscule est bien connu par la figure
d'un de ses fondateurs Charles Moras qui
qualifiait la République de gueuse et
qui a préparé les consciences à la
France de Vichy c'est ce même groupe
monsieur le ministre dont le manifeste
appelle à l'abolition de la République
c'est ce même groupe qui a déversé sa
haine et son racisme instant leurs idées
se sont aussi celles qui ont défilé dans
les rues de Lyon en toute impunité
vendredi soir dernier lors d'une
manifestation non déclarée client pour
seul objet la haine surfont sur une
récupération
ignoble du meurtre d'une enfant au mot
d'immigrés assassin monsieur le ministre
le maire de Lyon alerte particulièrement
depuis des semaines quant à la montée
des violences et pression venant de
mouvements xénophobe et d'extrême droite
dans sa ville car notre ADN c'est bien
celui du combat contre l'extrême droite
et tous nos concitoyens peu importe leur
couleur de peau leur origine ou leur
confessions ont le droit de vivre en
paix et en sécurité dans notre pays
monsieur le ministre devant la
représentation nationale nous vous
demandons quand le gouvernement va-t-il
prendre les seules mesures qui
s'imposent avec les groupes fascistes et
anti républicains à savoir leur
dissolution
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Sonia bacquest ministre en charge de la
citoyenneté
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée vous
interpellez le gouvernement sur
l'association Action française et vous
demandez sa dissolution administrative
cette association s'est signalée c'est
signalé à plusieurs reprises ils se sont
ils sont tentés de s'introduire dans
l'hémicycle du Conseil régional
d'Occitanie en mars dernier ces auteurs
ont été identifiés et ils feront l'objet
et c'est bien normal de mesures pénales
à titre individuel
toute tentative de s'en prendre aux
institutions de la République et de la
démocratie est inacceptable et appelle
une réponse immédiate
le gouvernement se montrera intraitable
contre toute atteinte aux institutions
un outil existe pour cela et vous l'avez
dit dans notre droit depuis 1936 la
dissolution administrative entre 2017 et
ce jour c'est 30 mesures de dissolution
administratives qui ont été prises elles
ont visé notamment des mouvements et
évolués dans évoluant dans la mouvance
djihadiste ou bien des mouvements
évoluant dans la sphère de
l'ultra-droite et c'est de celle là dont
vous parlez aujourd'hui car oui je veux
vous rassurer sur ce point les actions
des groupuscules d'ultra-droites font
l'objet d'une attention particulière et
chaque nouvelle élément fait l'objet
d'un examen minutieux afin de vérifier
s'il correspond ou non à l'un des motifs
définis par la loi
la preuve en est d'ailleurs avec la
dissolution en début d'année 2021 du
groupuscule génération identitaire
la loi du 24 août 2021 confortant le
respect des principes de la République à
étendu les motifs de dissolution
administrative d'association qui porte
atteinte au principe républicains ces
nouvelles dispositions ont permis la
dissolution administrative d'une dizaine
d'associations ou de groupements de
fêtes vous le voyez madame la députée la
main du gouvernement ne tremble pas dès
qu'il s'agit de faire échec à des
mouvements qui s'applent les fondements
de l'ordre républicain et ce sera le cas
sur cette association comme sur toutes
les autres je vous remercie je vous
remercie madame la députée alors je
repose ma question allez vous oui ou non
dissoudre l'association Action française
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
alors la parole est à Madame Véronique
BESSE madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre des
Solidarités de l'autonomie des personnes
handicapées monsieur le ministre je vais
aller droit au but à Caen une loi grand
âge c'était une promesse du président de
la République qui annonçait en 2018 que
cette loi je cite serait le marqueur
social du quinquennat depuis 4 ans nous
y avons cru mais en août dernier vous
avez annoncé son abandon et pourtant
l'espoir était grand pour nos aînés leur
famille mais aussi pour nous soignants
la création de la branche autonomie de
la sécurité sociale avait d'ailleurs
renforcé cet espoir plus que jamais il y
a urgence
urgence de donner davantage de moyens à
un secteur en grande souffrance
urgence de revaloriser des métiers qui
peinent à recruter
urgence d'affronter le boom de la
dépendance la France est confrontée à un
choc démographique sans précédent en
2050 la part des plus de 75 ans dans la
population
pas doublé elle passera de 8 à plus de
16%. je le ministre les quelques
propositions qui sont faites dans le
cadre du projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale ne sont pas à la
hauteur des enjeux ne sont pas dignes de
la compagnement que nous devons nous
anciens ne sont pas adaptés aux attentes
des familles et des personnels soignants
qu'attendez-vous pour lancer un grand
plan Marshall d'attractivité des métiers
du grand âge pour recruter dans les cinq
prochaines années 100 000 nouveaux
professionnels à domicile et en
établissement afin de faire face aux
besoins faudra-t-il de nouveaux
scandales dans nos EHPAD pour que le
gouvernement prenne le sujet du grand
âge au sérieux nous aînés leurs familles
ont besoin de toute notre empathie le
personnel soignant besoin de toute notre
reconnaissance mais au-delà des mots ils
veulent des actes nous voulons des actes
car nous sommes tous concernés par ce
sujet monsieur le ministre à Caen une
loi grand âge je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Christophe con ministre
des Solidarités de l'autonomie des
personnes handicapées merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée Véronique
BESSE merci pour votre question je suis
comme vous particulièrement préoccupé et
attaché à la question de la compagnement
des personnes âgées moi aussi je pense
qu'il faut passer des mots aux actes je
connais très bien cette question j'ai
acquis un certain nombre de de de
conviction à l'occasion de mes
précédentes fonctions à la Croix-Rouge
française nourrit de remonter du terrain
je sais que parmi et sur ces bancs de
nombreux députés partagent aussi des
constats des propositions aujourd'hui
tout est sur la table pour autant
beaucoup a été fait et des mesures
historiques ont été prises notamment
avec la création de la cinquième branche
vous l'avez dit et le dynamisme de cette
branche repose aujourd'hui vous le savez
pour l'heure sur un transfert d'une
fraction de CSG qui représent en 2024
plus de 2 milliards d'euros en 2024 les
dépenses de l'autonomie s'élèveront
environ 39 milliards d'euros soit 6
milliards et demi de plus qu'en 2021
c'est une dynamique qui est forte c'est
une dynamique qui traduit la trajectoire
que nous souhaitons pour revaloriser les
métiers du grand âge qui traduit aussi
notre investissement dans la rénovation
et la modernisation du parc des EHPAD
dans notre pays de virgule un milliard
d'euros d'investissement cette dynamique
elle va se poursuivre vous l'avez dit
avec le PLFSS 2023 qui est un pays FSS
ambitieux avec le lancement de la
trajectoire de recrutement de 50000
professionnels dans les EHPAD dont 3000
dès l'année prochaine qui font suite à
un à 15000 recrutements depuis 2017 avec
des contrôles qui vont être renforcés
pour que effectivement l'affaire hors pa
ne se reproduise pas demain et puis avec
un investissement fort sur le domicile
notamment sur les services de soins
infirmiers à domicile tout cela il faut
qu'on continue à le travailler je vous
l'ai dit on va continuer à porter dans
le cadre du CNR bien vieillir une
ambition forte merci Madame Besse vous
avez pas répondu à la question monsieur
le ministre et la loi grand âge dans
tout ça vos réponses ne sont pas à la
hauteur des attentes
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Hervé sur
Lignac pour le groupe socialiste merci
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de
l'économie monsieur le ministre je suis
sûr que vous aimez votre boulanger comme
la plupart des Français mais il va
falloir désormais en faire la
démonstration car il se trouve que
l'heure n'est plus au belle parole il
s'agit désormais de venir en aide très
vite à ces 30000 artisans boulanger
désespérés par la hausse folle des prix
de l'énergie après avoir subi celle des
matières premières aujourd'hui plusieurs
centaines de boulangers français ont
baissé leur rideau pour dénoncer cette
hausse mais beaucoup ne le feront pas
parce qu'il est impensable de perdre une
journée de travail quand on est déjà
pendu jusqu'à 500% d'augmentation et des
factures qui peuvent peser plus de 40%
du chiffre d'affaires ce sont des
boulangers qui ne peuvent plus se verser
leur salaire qui licencie parfois leur
personnel ou qui sont menacés de
redressement judiciaire les mesures que
vous avez prises sans les négliger c'est
trop peu trop tard et trop compliqué les
boulangers ont des besoins importants en
matière d'énergie en conséquence de quoi
beaucoup ont des compteurs électriques
supérieurs à 36 kg a se trouve pour 80%
d'entre eux exclus du bouclier tarifaire
nous boulanger sont sans solution ils ne
peuvent pas reporter des coups de
production exorbitants sur le
consommateur il ne savent pas s'ils
doivent signer le renouvellement de leur
contrat d'énergie devant les messages
contradictoires qui leur parviennent
l'une des plus grandes nations
productrices d'électricité va-t-elle
voir disparaître des artisans qui sont
le symbole de la France et le fer de
lance de son artisanat l'urgence est là
pour ces boulangers comme pour de
nombreux autres artisans commerçants
métiers de bouche restaurateurs ils
attendent des mesures rapides simples à
mettre en oeuvre je vous demande de leur
apporter des réponses claires et
efficaces et en leur nom je vous
remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'Économie des Finances de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
oui merci monsieur le député de poser
cette question ce qui me permet de bien
préciser quelles sont les mesures de
protection que nous allons apporter aux
entreprises c'est d'abord vous avez
toutes les très petites entreprises 1,5
millions d'entre elles qui sont protégés
par le bouclier tarifaire donc elles
sont déjà largement protégées dans ces
petites entreprises vous avez beaucoup
de boulanger et vous avez certains
boulangers vous avez parfaitement raison
qui ont une consommation supérieure à 36
kilos volts en pair et qui ne sont
malheureusement pas éligibles à ce
bouclier tarifaire pour ces entreprises
pour les PME pour un certain nombre
d'autres entreprises nous mettrons en
place une garantie électricité qui
permettra d'avoir un allègement direct
sur la facture d'électricité de ces
entreprises c'est le complément que nous
apportons et la réponse que nous allons
apporter au boulanger pour les
entreprises qui consomment plus
d'énergie ou qui sont au gaz et qui donc
ne peuvent pas bénéficier de cette
garantie énergie nous allons mettre en
place à partir du 15 novembre un guichet
pour le gaz qui va être extrêmement
simplifié je reconnais bien volontiers
que le guichet précédent était trop
complexe j'ai donné les règles qui
s'appliqueront il suffira d'avoir une
facture qui a augmenté de 150 % au lieu
d'avoir été multiplié par deux il
suffira d'avoir une augmentation de la
fin de l'année 2022 et de témoigner de
cette augmentation il faut que votre
énergie représente 3% de votre chiffre
d'affaires fin 2022 alors que avant
c'était fin 2021 et tout cela vous
donnera droit à des aides qui pourront
aller d'un montant de 4,50 millions
d'euros donc des montants qui sont
extrêmement élevés qui permettront de
couvrir des entreprises qui consomment
beaucoup d'énergie enfin vous devez
quelques cas très particuliers
d'entreprises energo intensive ou là la
facture peut se chiffrer en millions
d'euros et nous ferons du traitement au
cas par cas pour abandonner aucune
entreprise notre protection sera la plus
élevée que nous puissions apporter
est présente 10 millions 10 milliards
d'euros de charges supplémentaires pour
l'État mais mieux vaut dépenser ces 10
milliards d'euros que de menacer soit
des boulangers soit notre tissu
industriel je vous remercie monsieur
Solignac
merci monsieur le ministre pour votre
réponse je suis pas tout à fait
convaincu que tous les boulangers
trouvent réponse dans ce que vous venez
d'exprimer même si je le souhaite
j'insiste sur un point l'urgence de la
situation pour certains il est presque
déjà trop tard merci je vous remercie la
parole est à Monsieur David Daniel pour
le des gros Renaissance merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique monsieur le
ministre la loi de finances pour 2023
mettra en oeuvre une super contribution
pour les entreprises productrices
d'énergie taxer et restitué aux Français
ces rentes qui doivent tout presque au
hasard de la crise est une mesure
d'efficacité et de justice c'est une
mesure juste parce que la crise
s'appelle la solidarité de tous les
citoyens l'État les collectivités
locales font des efforts considérables
les entreprises consommatrices d'énergie
qui payent des factures très élevées
prennent toutes leurs parts il était
donc urgent que les entreprises
productrices d'énergie prennent aussi la
leur et grâce à notre majorité ce sera
chose faite
c'est une décision juste mais c'est
aussi une décision efficace parce qu'en
ayant obtenu que la même mesure soit
mise en oeuvre à travers toute l’union
européenne nous éviterons que certaines
entreprises contournent nos règles
nationales en délocalisant leurs
activités et en réduisant ainsi les
recettes de l'État monsieur le ministre
depuis 5 ans depuis la taxe Gafa jusqu'à
la réforme du marché de l'énergie en
passant par la réforme fiscale à l'ecde
le gouvernement s'est engagé pour mieux
réguler la mondialisation pour lutter
contre ces excès et ses dérives parce
que c'est la justice et il s'est engagé
pour le faire au niveau européen et au
niveau international parce que c'est
l'efficacité ma question est donc
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous nous
indiquer quels seront les prochaines
actions du gouvernement pour continuer à
faire mieux respecter les choix de la
France dans la mondialisation
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député David Amiel merci de rappeler une
chose que j'ai assez peu entendu sur les
bancs de cette hémicycle et que je crois
profondément vrai vous êtes la majorité
de la justice fiscale
vous êtes la majorité la justice fiscale
parce que vous avez été les premiers à
mettre en place la taxation sur les
géants du numérique pour laquelle nous
sommes battus depuis 5 ans
avec le soutien d'un certain nombre de
pays européens dont d'ailleurs la
Grande-Bretagne du nouveau chancelier
richissudac vous avez été le premier
pays européen à défendre l'idée d'une
taxation minimale à l'impôt sur les
sociétés qui s'est désormais imposée
partout à le CDE et que nous mettrons en
place au niveau national en janvier
prochain si jamais nous n'arrivons pas à
arracher l'accord de la Hongrie les
partenaires du rassemblement national
qui bloquent cette puce de justice
fiscale depuis maintenant plusieurs mois
vous avez été la première majorité à
mettre en place un prélèvement sur les
rentes des énergéticiens mesures
autrement plus efficace que la taxation
sur les super profits autrement plus
juste et autrement plus rentable pour
les comptes de l'État qu'elle va
rapporter 26 milliards d'euros en 20223
au compte public la différence entre
vous et l'opposition c'est que vous ne
confondez pas justice fiscale et
vengeance fiscale vous avez parfaitement
compris
que dans un pays qui a déjà un taux de
prélèvement obligatoire parmi les plus
élevés plutôt que de les taxer toutes
les entreprises pour 5 ans un défilément
alors qu'elles sont déjà confrontées à
des difficultés économiques majeures il
est préférable il est meilleur et il est
plus efficace de continuer à taxer les
Gafa de mettre en place la position
minimale l'impôt sur les sociétés et de
prélever la rente sur les énergéticiens
pour financer la protection des Français
contre l'inflation
si Monsieur le Ministre la parole est à
Monsieur romain Baudry pour le groupe
rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur le
ministre je reviens vers vous car il y a
quelques temps en commission des lois je
vous ai posé une question à laquelle
vous n'avez pas répondu au sujet de la
vague de suicide chez les forces de
l'ordre et nombreux sont ceux qui
attendent de des réponses mais au-delà
des réponses ils attendent avant tout
des actes car derrière ces drames il y a
des familles et notamment des enfants
des amis et des collègues jour après
jour ils sont découragés par une justice
inefficace qui les oblige à interpeller
continuellement les mêmes individus tout
en laissant alors sort les victimes qui
s'accumulent ils sont stigmatisés par
les extrêmes gauchistes qui multiplient
chaque jour un jour et propos haineux
ils sont utilisés par ce gouvernement
pour remplir des tableaux statistiques
et victimes de pratique managériale
d'une haute hiérarchie plus politique
que flic ils sont à bout c'est 20
dernières années on ne content que les
suicides dans la police nationale ce
sont plus de 1200 Pol qui ont mis fin à
leur jour je me pose la question de
savoir où sont les budgets qui devaient
servir à proposer des solutions
concrètes et efficaces pour endiguer le
phénomène
ne me parlez pas du numéro d'appel ou
bien de psychologue supplémentaires vous
qui aimez les statistiques et les
chiffres voyez que ces mesures étaient
n'ont aucun effet et que nous comptons
toujours plus de morts il faut agir bien
en amont pour être réellement dans la
prévention avant le point de non-retour
et c'est d'ailleurs ce que j'ai défendu
en commission des lois il y a quelques
jours mais ma proposition sans surprise
a été balayée d'un revers de la main par
là ensemble des groupes politiques
autres que le rassemblement national
lorsqu’un membre des forces de l'ordre
actionne la queue de détente il n'est
pas le seul à poser son doigt dessus il
y a des responsables mais où sont-ils
chez France Télécom les responsables ont
été traduits devant la justice donc
monsieur le ministre quand allez-vous
enfin prendre des mesures concrètes pour
endiguer la vague de suicide qui dessine
jour après jour les rangs de nos forces
de l'ordre je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Sonia bac S
secrétaire d'État à la citoyenneté
dans la précédente mesdames et messieurs
les députés monsieur le député d'abord
je veux rendre hommage à l'action à
l'action de nos forces de l'ordre au
quotidien qui chaque jour protège nos
concitoyens avec toute l'énergie dont
ils sont capables et je veux répéter ici
que le ministre de l'Intérieur est
extrêmement attentif et toujours
toujours à la défense des policiers et
des gendarmes sur le terrain
ensuite je veux dire tout le toute le
travail qui a été fait sur le terrain
ces cinq dernières années avec 10000
policiers et gendarmes supplémentaires
et ça c'est bien le quinquennat
précédent qu'il a fait et pas les
quinquennat qui ont précédé
ensuite je veux dire toute l'ambition
qui est celle du ministre de l'Intérieur
dans la loop me qui est à l'examen
aujourd'hui d'abord c'est 8500 policiers
gendarmes en plus ensuite c'est un
investissement majeur en matière de
cybersécurité qui est en cours c'est une
hausse globale de 15 milliards 15
milliards
qui vont venir au service de nos
policiers c'est 200 nouvelles brigades
c'est 11 unités de force mobile et tout
ça tout ça pour améliorer les conditions
pas dans les conditions de nos forces de
sécurité merci beaucoup
je vous remercie madame la minée s'il
vous plaît mes chers collègues vous avez
deux secondes
[Musique]
et pour les suicides
merci la parole est à Monsieur Olivier
Servat pour le groupe liotte
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre des Outre-mer chers collègues
j'associe à cette question madame
Estelle Youssoupha alors où je m'adresse
à vous plus de 40000 foyers guadeloupés
sont privés d'eau beaucoup le son depuis
le passage de la tempête Fiona en
septembre dernier Monsieur le Ministre
ces chiffres appellent à s'interroger
sur le déploiement avec une intensité
suffisante du plan Orsec eau potable
j'ai sollicité la mise en place de ce
dispositif au lendemain du passage de la
tempête après avoir été sensibilisé par
le collectif Moon Guadeloupe aujourd'hui
il reste insuffisant tous les jours je
suis interpellé par des Guadeloupéens
notamment des personnes âgées isolées
qui n'ont pas d'eau habitant de
Chauffour aux Abymes dans le périmètre
du plan en sec eau potable mes voisins
et moi même sont privés d'eau depuis 5
jours
ça se détérior quotidiennement payer un
pack d'aujourd'hui plus de 5 euros
lorsque ce liquide vital ne coule pas
dans les robinets relève de l'agression
monsieur le ministre 3 je souhaite
également attirer votre attention sur
Mayotte sur l'île un tiers de la
population n'a pas accès à l'eau et
seulement 18 % du réseau et raccordé à
l'assainissement que faites-vous pour
vos citoyens français de Mayotte et de
Guadeloupe je vous remercie la parole
est à Monsieur Jean-François carlinko
ministre en charge des Outre-mer
madame la Présidente Mesdames Messieurs
les Députés monsieur le député Servat la
situation de en Guadeloupe est
prioritaire et mobilise force immobilise
fortement le ministère nul ne peut en
douter le mobilise tout le gouvernement
et notamment la servi de la sécurité
civile sur l'autorité directe de
Monsieur Darmanin vous le savez le plan
Orsec a été déclenché de manière
exceptionnelle et non pas pour résoudre
des problèmes structurels qui sont ceux
de la Guadeloupe et pas ceux du
l'ouragan Fiona ce plan visa provisionné
en nous les lieux publics les plus
sensibles hôpitaux personnes fragile
isolées après la tempête Fiona après la
tempête finale nous avons constaté en
plus de nombreux dégâts sur les prises
d'eau et notamment sur le gros feeder de
bellocado qui approvisionne tout le sud
de la Grande Terre et chez vous monsieur
le député cette casse est majeure et
mérite des travaux lourds pour cette
face à cette situation la préfecture a
activé sans opérationnelle
départementale concrètement cela veut
dire module de potabilisation installée
à Fouillole avec 45 logisticiens venus
spécialement de la métropole surtout
pour les zones du sud de la Grande Terre
distribution aux 5 octobre de 1300
palettes un million de litres d'eau
500000 litres en citerne une solution de
réparation provisoire du feeder était
trouvé d'ici mi-novant et une solution
définitive sera trouvée pour Noël
en parallèle
sur les problèmes structurels et c'est
là le plus important mon directeur de
cabinet s'est rendu sur place la semaine
du 11 octobre ainsi qu'une mission
interministériale afin de se mettre tous
d'accord sur les besoins et les
modalités d'accompagnement renforcés du
SMIC nous sommes tombés d'accord
sur les 9 points qui étaient en cause et
une convention sera signée dans les deux
prochaines semaines
je suis donc très optimiste pour régler
enfin impressionnant les problèmes d'eau
en Guadeloupe
s'agissant s'agissant de Mayotte qui
arrive juste comme ça un contrat de 400
millions d'euros a été signé et je ne
ferai pas le président de Mayotte merci
Monsieur le Ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Yannick Favennec Bécaud pour le
groupe horizon merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre des Solidarités si
les projecteurs ont été braqués ces
dernières semaines sur les aides à
domicile en raison notamment des
pénuries d'essence je veux aujourd'hui
les remettre au centre de nos
préoccupations mais cette fois pour
réitérer l'urgence d'une réforme
profonde de leur profession
ces aides à domicile nous le savons tous
sont indispensables il et elle
œuvre tous les jours dans des conditions
parfois très difficiles auprès de
personnes âgées et handicapées en perte
d'autonomie afin de leur permettre de
rester chez elle le plus longtemps
possible
leur vocation c'est aider soutenir
accompagner mais beaucoup sont épuisés
découragés démotiver le résultat c'est
une véritable crise de recrutement je le
constate malheureusement tous les jours
de mon département de la Mayenne
pourtant leur rôle est plus que jamais
essentiel et la conjoncture celle d'une
société vieillissante implique une
réforme dont le contenu est loin d'être
démesuré mais légitime rationnelle et
tout simplement humain prise en compte
des temps de déplacement entre chaque
patient revalorisation réelle des
indemnités kilométriques définition d'un
vrai statut mise mis en place une
formation reconnue et augmentation
salariale par conséquent ma question est
simple monsieur le ministre quand et
comment allez-vous répondre concrètement
aux attentes de ces femmes et de ses
hommes qui sont aussi nos héros du
quotidien
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Christophe
solidarité de l'autonomie et des
personnes handicapées
le Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le députés Yannick
Favennec vous avez raison les
professionnels de l'aide à domicile
traversent depuis plusieurs années une
crise profonde crise d'attractivité
d'abord du métier alors qu'augmente les
besoins de la population et que
s'accumulent les contraintes pour ces
femmes et ses hommes engagés qui
accompagnent au quotidien nos
concitoyens âgés ou en situation de
handicap crise du recrutement vous
l'avez dit qui exacerbe les tensions
déjà existantes
crises de la pratique professionnelle
alors qu'on sait par exemple que
l'exposition à un risque d'accident du
travail et de maladies professionnelles
ce que l'on appelle la sinistralité et
chez ses aides à domicile plus élevées
que dans le que dans le BTP face à cela
une urgence agir pour redonner du sens
aux métiers soutenir ses professionnels
dont nous avons tant besoin pour réussir
le virage domiciliaire qu'appelle de
leur vœu l'immense majorité des Français
comme pour les EHPAD nous avons déjà
pris des mesures fortes ces dernières
années
pour l'aide à domicile des
revalorisations salariales historiques
avec l'avenant 43 de la branche d'aide à
domicile ce sont des augmentations de
plus de 15% pouvant aller jusqu'à 250
euros par mois pour près de plus de 210
000 professionnels qu'on pensait à 50 %
par l'État et donc c'est pas seulement
les départements qui augmentent les
salaires une dotation qualité pour les
services d'aide à domicile pour
permettre à la fois de mieux couvrir les
zones soudances et d'améliorer les
conditions de travail des professionnels
ainsi qu'à tarif plancher pour les
heures d'aide de services à domicile qui
sera revalorisé cette année à 23 euros
là aussi à 100% compensé par l'État pour
les soins infirmiers à domicile avec le
PLFSS 2023 on va aussi investir
augmenter le nombre de places dans les
services de soins infirmiers à domicile
pour l'augmenter de 20% d'ici à 2030
c'est un investissement de 400 millions
d'euros en année pleine pour réformer
aussi le financement de ces services
en prenant en compte mieux en compte la
situation des personnes merci Monsieur
le Ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Mathias Tavel pour le groupe la
princesse soumise
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre le premier janvier le
prix du gaz et de l'électricité
augmenteront de 15 % pour les Français
les TPE et les petites collectivités qui
sont pourtant bénéficiaires du bouclier
tarifaire plus 15% ce n'est plus un
bouclier c'est un matraquage tarifaire
que vous préparez
pour un ménage cela représente 300 euros
de plus par an qui iront pour une bonne
partie dans les poches des actionnaires
d'engie ou de Total énergie
madame la Première ministre vous
préparez un autre mauvais coup sur
lequel vous êtes bien silencieux
le premier juillet 2023 dans quelques
mois à peine votre gouvernement privera
les Français du tarif réglementé du gaz
en supprimant purement et simplement
leur existence
vous vous soumettez ainsi au dogme
européen de la concurrence et de la
marchandisation de l'énergie
or c'est grâce à ces tarifs réglementés
que vous pouvez décider des boucliers
tarifaires la réalité c'est donc que
votre bouclier tarifaire est un bouclier
à obsolescence programmé madame la
Première ministre au lieu de jouer un
mauvais épisode d'inspecteur gadget à
Bruxelles chaque semaine
qu'attendez-vous pour bloquer les prix
et renoncer à la hausse de 15% au 1er
janvier
qu'attendez-vous pour désobéir aux
règles européennes et prolonger les
tarifs réglementés du gaz au-delà du 1er
juillet
qu'attendez-vous pour permettre à tous
les particuliers toutes les entreprises
et toutes les collectivités de revenir
au tarif réglementés enfin
qu'attendez-vous pour rompre avec la
participation de la France au délirant
marché européen de l'énergie pour
reprendre les mots de votre Ministre
allez vous continuer à faire payer aux
Français les diktats de Monsieur Poutine
de la Commission européenne ou de
l'Allemagne
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
ministre de l'Économie des Finances de
la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique le député
que la France est de loin le pays
européen qui a le mieux protégé ses
compatriotes contre l'augmentation des
prix de l'électricité et du gaz
vous avez oublié que c'est le seul pays
en Europe le seul qui est mis en place
dès octobre 2021 au moment où les prix
commençaient à flamber un plafonnement
des prix du gaz et un gel est près du
gaz un plafonnement des prix de
l'électricité à
4%, vous avez oublié que si nous
n'étions pas intervenus la facture des
français ce qui nous écoutent ceux qui
sont ici dans l'hémicycle elle aurait
augmenté de 180 euros pour l'électricité
par mois et de 200 euros pour le gaz par
mois donc oui il y a un bouclier oui il
protège et oui cette majorité est la
seule en Europe à l'avoir fait avec
autant d'efficacité
pour l'avenir bien entendu que nous
sommes décidés à défendre les boucliers
tarifaires à défendre un tarif régulé de
l'énergie et d'ailleurs ce tarif
régulier d'énergie il continue à exister
comment voudriez-vous aujourd'hui que
nous protions les petites collectivités
plus de 20.000 d'entre elles les petites
entreprises plus de 1,5 millions
d'entraide si nous n'avions pas ce tarif
régulé que nous avons toujours défendu
et toujours maintenu en France au niveau
européen monsieur le député vous avez
oublié une chose je crois c'est que le
choc inflationniste c'est 3% du PIB
comme choc économique qui pèse sur nos
compatriotes et sur notre économie et
que ce choc-là il est absorbé à 55% par
l'État
à 40% par les entreprises
et à 5% seulement par les ménages aucun
autre État européen n'a autant protégé
les ménages que nous ne l'avons fait
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame Daniel brûlebois
pour le groupe Renaissance merci madame
la Présidente ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur et
des Outre-mer ce mois d'août a été
marqué en France par de tragiques
incendie dans le Jura où ils ont dévasté
1200 hectares de forêt nous avons frôlé
le pire alors que les flammes sont
venues menacer les habitations jusqu'au
cœur de plusieurs villages et à Meaux si
nous n'avons à déplorer aucune victime
aucun blessé aucune habitation brûlée
nous le devons à l'engagement courageux
exemplaire de nos apports pompiers
professionnels et volontaires des jours
et des nuits durant ils ont mené une
lutte acharnée contre des murs de
flammes et des tourbillons de feu
imprévisibles dans des conditions
extrêmes et hostiles vous avez été
constamment à notre écoute monsieur le
ministre et vous nous avez envoyé des
moyens aériens conséquents et salvateurs
Canadair avion dash hélicoptère avec ma
collègue députée du Jura marie-christ
nous vous en remercions
nos centres de secours et d'incendie ont
pu compter sur l'aide déterminante des
agriculteurs qui se sont mobilisés
spontanément jour et nuit armés de leur
tonne alisiers ils ont fait gagner un
temps précieux aux pompiers les
ravitaillants en eau et à l'entrée aussi
au front arroser les feux et les abords
des villages pour les protéger le
président de la République a salué
l'immense élan de solidarité jurassien
l'engagement des mers élus pompiers
gendarmes bénévoles et l'aide à portée
par les agriculteurs ma question est la
suivante alors que les agriculteurs ont
engagé sans compter leur force leur
matériel leur moyen laissant les travaux
de leur ferme pouvez-vous nous dire
monsieur le ministre où en est le
versement de l'indemnisation bien
légitime qui leur a été promise
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Caroline caillot ministre délégué chargé
des collectivités territoriales
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Daniel brûlebois comme vous l'avez dit
les feux du Jura cet été ont été
particulièrement ravageurs avec plus de
1200 hectares qui ont brûlé
principalement sur deux communes
cernon-évêque l'état vous l'avez salué a
été présent aux côtés des
sapeurs-pompiers et des élus locaux plus
de 200 sapeurs-pompiers trois canadaires
indache un et deux hélicoptères mais là
aussi vous l'avez salué les d'autres
acteurs sont entrés je dirais se sont
engagés au service de ces incendies qui
ont les agriculteurs qui ont apporté de
l'eau pour ravitailler des camions
contre le feu des noyages de lisière et
en effet lors d'un contact téléphonique
avec les élus locaux le président de la
République s'est engagé à ce qu'une
compensation puisse être reversée aux
agriculteurs qui avaient œuvré lors de
cette action collective et de
préservation du massif jurassien cette
procédure d'indemnisation est prise en
charge de manière un peu plus globale
puisque sont également concernés les
frais liés au feu de la Gironde je veux
donc vous rassurer les procédures sont
en cours nous attendons encore quelques
éléments de factures pour obtenir les
crédits nécessaires pour pouvoir ainsi
procéder rapidement aux indemnisations
nécessaires avant de conclure je
voudrais évidemment à mon tour saluer
cette solidarité sur le terrain qui fait
honneur à notre pays je vous remercie
madame olbois messe est tenu je vous
remercie madame la ministre merci
beaucoup la parole est à Madame Caroline
Colombier pour le groupe rassemblement
national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires monsieur le ministre trop
c'est trop alors que chaque jour nos
territoires ruraux luttent contre les
départs des médecins de famille contre
la fermeture de classe et des commerces
de proximité et bien d'autres mots
encore voici qu'ils sont en train de
mourir à petit feu sur l'hôtel de la
pseudo transition écologique les
gouvernements successifs leur donnent le
coup de grâce par l'implantation massive
et anarchique d'éolienne en dépit de la
colère montante des riverains et des
associations
ces territoires sont devenus
laboratoires du sacro-saint-dogmatisme
écolo idéologique exploitée par des
promoteurs autoritaires et sans
scrupules sur fond de pauvreté de misère
sociale
faisons pression sur les mairies des
petites communes sur les mers des
petites communes l'implantation se fait
à marche forcée à la demande du
Président de la République les
administrations régionales sont même en
train de dresser des cartes prospectives
des zones propices au développement de
futurs parcs y compris dans des zones de
nature à ce titre à titre d'exemple la
troisième circonscription de la Charente
dont je suis l'élu possède déjà une
centaine d'éoliennes plus 100 en cours
de construction 300 en instruction
atteignant ce ratio lamentable d'une
éolienne pour 6 habitants dans certaines
communes
ne voyez-vous pas les conséquences
délétères de cette politique baisse de
l'attractivité des territoires nuisances
sonores permanente dévalorisation
immobilière saccage de nos paysages
défiguration du patrimoine
bouleversement de la faune et de la
flore tout cela parfois à proximité
directe de monuments historiques classés
ou de cœur d'espace protégés Natura 2000
monsieur le ministre écoutez les
riverains plongés dans le désarroi et
tenté par la colère dont je me fais
aujourd'hui l'écho combien de temps
monsieur le ministre encore nos
territoires continueront-ils à subir ces
choix inconséquents et néfastes en
matière énergétique merci beaucoup la
parole est à Monsieur Christophe Béchu
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre madame la députée Caroline
Colombier vous me permettrez d'abord
d'excuser la ministre de la transition
énergétique qui aurait été heureuse de
vous répondre Agnès renacher qui est
retenu pour le Conseil des ministres de
l'énergie précisément pour discuter de
la situation actuelle de la réforme du
marché de l'électricité
nous avons aujourd'hui
une situation énergétique dont nous
n'avons sans doute jamais autant parlé
et dans cette situation énergétique il y
a quelques balises dans ces balises il y
a un consensus des experts de RTE sur le
fait que si nous voulons nous
débarrasser des énergies fossiles qui
sont responsables du réchauffement
climatique qui sont responsables aussi
de la pollution atmosphérique nous
devons augmenter la part de nos énergies
renouvelables dans ces énergies
renouvelables nous avons
l'hydro-électricité nous avons
évidemment aussi les éoliennes et le
solaire les éoliennes c'est environ pour
vous répondre
l'équivalent en production de la
consommation de 8 millions de nos
concitoyens
et ça participe à hauteur de 8% de notre
mix énergétique c'est 22 000 emplois et
c'est une répartition sur le territoire
qui vous avez raison suscite de lever de
bouclier parce que il n'y en a pas
partout des secteurs où il y en a
beaucoup des secteurs où il y en a
nettement moins mais les arguments qui
consistent à dire que ça ne marche pas
sont à peu près aussi crédibles que ceux
qui sont climatosceptiques dans ce
contexte l'engagement du président de la
République c'est d'abord d'augmenter la
part de nos énergies renouvelables pour
tendre vers les 33% et le projet de loi
dont vous serez soumis sur
l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables portent sur deux types
d'énergie sur lequel nous voulons
accélérer
le photovoltaïque et les éoliens
offshore pour les éoliennes terrestres
il y a un régime d'encadrement il y a la
demande d'avis des maires il y a la mise
en place par les élus locaux de
territoire qui définissent les zones sur
lesquelles ces projets peuvent être
portés on n'est pas convaincus par le
tout Etien on est pour un mixte
nucléaire et aux liens offshore
photovoltaïque éolien terrestre merci
Monsieur le Ministre
la parole est à Madame Josiane cornelot
pour le groupe lettres merci madame la
Présidente
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
je suis interpellée par des dirigeants
de TPE PME de masse circonscription qui
sont très inquiets de la situation
actuelle cette inquiétude est plus
largement partagée par les 6 millions
d'indépendants et de dirigeants de
pmetpe qui ont peur du lendemain avec
l'explosion des prix de l'énergie nos
PME TPE sont au bord de la faillite la
France produit son électricité à 50
euros le mégawattheure grâce à notre
parc nucléaire unique en Europe mais les
entreprises l'achètent au prix délirant
de 600 700 euros les mécanismes de
protection mise en place par votre
gouvernement pour les entreprises sont
largement insuffisants et les mesures
européennes n'en finissent plus de
tarder on ne peut pas dire aux
entreprises de ne rien signer comme l'a
dit le président de la République il y a
un mois et dénoncé à longueur
d'interviews des prix fous et ne pas
défendre concrètement nos entreprises
les mesures proposées aujourd'hui sont
totalement insuffisantes les TPE sont
exclus aujourd'hui du dispositif seuls
certaines PME y sont éligibles au
demeurant selon des critères trop
complexes on ne peut plus attendre il en
va de la survie de nos entreprises il en
va de notre compétitivité nationale nous
demandons l'élargissement du bouclier
tarifaire à toutes les PME et TPE avec
des critères simples et juste par
ailleurs 700 000 TPE ont eu recours au
PGE qui ont pris fin le 30 juin 2022 un
indépendant devra consacrer en moyenne
564 euros par mois pour son
remboursement soit plus de 6% de son
chiffre d'affaires pendant quatre ans
auquel s'ajoute le remboursement des
dettes sociales contractées auprès de
l'URSSAF soit au total d'imensualités
comprises entre 500 et 1000 euros la
Cour des comptes évalue à 160 000 le
nombre d'entreprises très fragilisées
par cette situation
monsieur le ministre il y a urgence quel
dispositif global d'aide comptez-vous
mettre en place et avec quel calendrier
pour donner les moyens à nos entreprises
d'affronter ces chocs successifs je vous
remercie je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
ministre de l'économie et des finances
la présidente
évidemment votre inquiétude sur la
situation de beaucoup d'entreprises
beaucoup de PME qui font face à des prix
électricité des prix du gaz des factures
qui sont multipliées par 2 3 5 10 dans
des proportions qui sont totalement
déraisonnables nous avons d'abord
rassemblé des fournisseurs leur demander
de proposer à toutes les entreprises des
prix raisonnables dans des conditions
raisonnables et nous veillons à ce que
cette charte des fournisseurs soit
respectée je l'ai déjà indiqué tous ceux
qui ne respecteraient pas cette charte
cela arrive encore leur nom seront
rendus publics en deuxième lieu nous
voulons que toutes les entreprises tout
est très petites entreprises 1,5
millions de entreprises est accès aux
tarifs réguliers c'est le cas nous y
veillerons et pour ceux qui sont en
situation particulière je pense au
boulanger donc nous allons parler tout à
l'heure nous avons mis en place une
garantie électricité qui sera précisée
dans les heures qui viennent par la
première ministre c'est le garantie
d'électricité elle vaudra pour 2023 elle
portera sur toutes les PME toutes les
TPE tous les indépendants dont vous avez
parlé et elles permettra de faire un
allègement de la facture d'énergie
directement du fournisseur au client de
façon à ce que la facture soit moins
lourde pour les entreprises qui sont
plus importantes et qui ont besoin
d'allongement plus significatif elle
elles auront droit un traitement au cas
par cas pour celles qui se fournissent
en gaz puisque la garantie ne porte que
ceux d'électricité elles auront droit à
un guichet sur le gaz qui leur permettra
de rembourser une partie de leur facture
énergétique j'ai parfaitement conscience
je l'ai déjà plusieurs reprises que le
guichet à sa première version était
infiniment trop compliqué il n'a pas
fonctionné nous avons demandé à
allègement une simplification des
critères à la Commission européenne nous
avons obtenu cet allègement nous avons
obtenu cette simplification ce guichet
sera ouvert au 15 novembre avait des
critères simplifiés pour protéger les
entreprises je partage une fois encore
vos inquiétudes nos réponses seront
massives puissantes et efficaces merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre la parole
est à Madame Elodie Jack et la forge
pour le groupe modem
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur Jean-Noël barreau
ministre délégué déchargé de la
transition numérique et des
télécommunications et elle porte sur les
zones blanches persistantes à la fois
pour le réseau mobile et pour le fixe
pour assurer une couverture mobile sur
tout le territoire et résorber la
fracture numérique le gouvernement a
depuis quatre ans engagé le New Deal le
New Deal mobile mais les opérateurs de
téléphonie mobile quant à eux n'ont pas
toujours rempli leur part de leur du
contrat en effet de trop nombreuses
communes sont encore aujourd'hui touché
par l'absence totale ou partielle du
réseau
entre couverture inexistante et coupure
régulière la situation de ses habitants
leur est insupportable alors que tous
nos concitoyens ont besoin de leur
téléphone se pose également la question
de la sécurité des habitants mais aussi
des touristes sachez qu'en Isère dans le
secteur du royaume Vercors même le
réseau s'affirent pourtant utilisé par
nos forces de gendarmerie est
inaccessible dans certaines zones assez
difficultés de réseaux mobiles
s'ajoutent des problèmes sur le réseau
filaire toujours pas rénovés dans
certains territoires c'est donc une
double peine
pour les habitants qui n'ont donc ni
réseau mobile stable ni réseau fixe
fiable et encore moins la fibre bien
évidemment donc face à ces défaillances
j'avais personnellement sollicité orange
l'opérateur historique qui m'avait
répondu alors je cite il frottera bien
vivre avec le réseau existant monsieur
le ministre les citoyens et les élus
particulièrement des zones rurales et de
montagnes ne voient pas leur situation
s'améliorer et s'impatiente alors où le
télétravail s'est imposé pour beaucoup
ces zones blanches pointent les
inégalités territoriales de notre pays
et rendent ces régions moins attractives
je connais votre engagement sur ce sujet
et je sais pouvoir compter sur votre
implication ma question est donc comment
comptez-vous mettre les opérateurs face
à leur responsabilité je vous remercie
ma chère collègues la parole est un
chant de Noël barreau ministre délégué
chargé de la transition numérique et des
télécommunications merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée la France ne
tiendra son rang de grande nation du
numérique que si l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens sont desservis par les
réseaux télécommunications fixes et
mobiles et lorsque toutes les zones
blanches auront été effacées s'agissant
des réseaux fixes le plan France très
haut débit initié il y a 10 ans se
poursuit se déploie la France et le pays
le mieux fibré en Europe mais il faut
veiller au rythme et à la qualité des
déploiements et c'est la responsabilité
de l'ARCEP de le faire s'agissant du
mobile je veux rendre hommage à Julien
de Normandie à Jacqueline Gouraud à
Cédrico qui constatant les difficultés
des opérateurs à couvrir certaines zones
peu dense on quitte initié le programme
du New Deal mobile qui était un
programme de réussite de confiance de
coopération entre l'État les
collectivités et les opérateurs puisque
c'est au niveau départemental que sont
identifiés les lieux d'implantation des
sites et ça fonctionne en quelques
années plusieurs milliers de zones
blanches ont été effacées 3795 pour être
exact donc 49 dans votre département
madame la députée il faut évidemment
aller plus loin puisque l'objectif
c'était de couvrir 5000 sites en 2025 et
en 2023
600 sites seront attribués dont 9 dans
votre département dans votre
circonscription quatre communes sont
encore classifiées en zone blanche elles
ont été
identifiées en zone prioritaire et je
peux d'ores et déjà vous annoncer que
pour trois d'entre elles chorange
Chatelus Saint-Pierre de cherene et
Presles les implantations auront lieu
d'ici 18 mois vous le voyez madame la
députée mesdames et messieurs les
députés nous travaillons
papier pour faire en sorte que
s'agissant du fixe ou du mobile
l'ensemble du territoire national soit
couvert que les zones blanches soient
totalement effacées avec une vigilance
particulière pour les zones de montagne
et pour les zones rurales
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Christophe n'est
je l'aime pour le groupe liote merci
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues la presse
vosgienne se fait aujourd'hui le relais
d'un courrier que vous auriez reçu du
président du groupe avec propriétaire
depuis 2011 des termes de
Plombières-les-Bains au sein de ma
circonscription vosgienne ce groupe qui
recense 12000 salariés est un habitué
des rachats d'entreprises en difficulté
qui ne respectent d'ailleurs pas ces
engagements pris devant les tribunaux
au-delà des termes de Plombières dont la
réouverture a été poussée repoussée déjà
à quatre reprises mettant ainsi les
salariés la commune ces acteurs
économiques et tout le territoire en
grande difficulté se pose la question de
la gestion globale de ce groupe orienté
dans le domaine de la santé il est
largement bénéficiaire de son public et
sa réputation fureuse interroge que ce
soit dans les Vosges avec les termes de
Plombières ou à Grenoble avec sa
clinique de plus dans son équipe
dirigeante on retrouve d'anciens
ministres d'anciens élus et même
derrière moi un ancien directeur de la
banque des territoires et sont dirigeant
lui-même laisse sous-entendre
ouvertement ses forces soutien politique
je n'oserais croire les rumeurs de
protection et de copinage politique dont
bénéficierait le président d'avec madame
la Première ministre éclairez-nous et
rassurez-nous sur ces manœuvres enfin à
quand la convocation demandée depuis
plus de six mois des représentants de
cette société dans les bureaux de Bercy
afin de trouver non seulement une
solution à la situation catastrophique
de Plombières mais plus globalement sur
le contrôle de l'utilisation et de la
gestion de l'argent public par ce groupe
je vous remercie la parole est à madame
la Première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
co-président Christophe najlaine la
situation que vous décrivez dans votre
circonscription et bien connu des
équipes des ministères des solidarités
et de celle du ministre du ministère de
l'Économie nous avons affaire à un
investisseur qui ne respecte pas ses
engagements qui ne respectent pas les
acteurs du territoire qui lui ont fait
confiance qui ne respectent pas les
salariés des termes de Plombières alors
monsieur le Président nous connaissons
ce type de pratique nous leur faisons la
chasse et nous savons qu'il faut être
très attentif à la préservation des
emplois et je peux vous assurer que le
ministère de l'économie est
spécifiquement le ministre Roland
Lescure sont très mobilisés sur ce sujet
et je vous le dis aussi très clairement
nous ne laisserons pas des acteurs
financiers opportunistes chercher les
appuis sans jamais tenir leurs
engagements nous serons extrêmement
exigeants avec le groupe que vous
évoquez qui est un employeur important
dans votre région et je vous le dis
également il n'y a il n'y aura aucune
complaisance aucune facilité aucune
naïveté des pouvoirs publics vis-à-vis
de ce groupe quel que soit les soutiens
imaginaires qu'il invoquent nous
n'acceptons pas ces dérives et partout
cet acteur est implanté j'ai demandé au
service de l'État d'être attentif
exigeant et réactif vous pouvez compter
sur notre mobilisation je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre monsieur le Président negelaine
Madame la première ministre merci
réellement un grand merci pour votre
réponse car les propos de ce président
laissé sous-entendre certains points qui
jetaient le propre sur tous les élus et
sur le gouvernement merci madame la
Première ministre merci beaucoup la
parole est à Delphine bateau pour le
groupe écologiste merci madame la
Présidente
chers collègues la terre des Deux-Sèvres
comme tant d'autres en France et en
danger immédiat du fait des impacts du
changement climatique
cinquième vague de chaleur deux alertes
rouges canicules record d'incendie de
culture 1000 km d'àsecte dans les
rivières des pertes de récolte pour les
agricultrices et les agriculteurs et
l'eau potable en situation de danger
critique face à la pénurie d'eau nous
avions fait il y a des années le pari du
dialogue ce dialogue avait débouché sur
un protocole pour réduire l'irrigation
et transformer obligatoirement les
pratiques agricoles pour sortir des
pesticides des engrais replantés des ce
protocole madame la Première ministre
n'existe plus car l'état la piétiné les
associations et les élus qui ont cru au
dialogue ont été rouler dans la farine
pour le pour l'État ce protocole n'était
qu'une devanture pour conduire tambour
battant les travaux de construction de
grande réserves d'irrigations madame la
Première ministre vous êtes face à vos
responsabilités allez-vous prononcer
l'arrêt des travaux allez-vous organiser
un référendum local pour que les
habitants et les habitants décident de
la gestion de ce bien commun qui est
l'eau ou bien allez vous passer en force
pour faire des Deux-Sèvres et du Marais
Poitevin le laboratoire d'essai de la
guerre de l'eau qui couvre partout dans
le pays
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
madame la présidente
madame la députée Delphine bateau
alors où nous parlons la moitié des
départements de ce pays
sont encore confrontés à une
insuffisance pluviométrie qui nous amène
à maintenir des arrêtés de crise ou des
arrêtés de restriction principalement
dans trois des divers bassins sur
lesquels aujourd'hui notre pays assure
cette gestion de l'eau
et en posant cette question vous
rappelez que c'est un sujet dont tout le
monde parle au mois d'août et donc plus
personne ne se préoccupe au mois de
septembre quand avec Bérengère Couillard
quand avec Agnès Firma lovodo fin
septembre nous avons effectivement fait
en sorte de lancer des assises de l'eau
avec la totalité du Conseil national
avec tous les présidents de bassin avec
l'ensemble des élus locaux pour
lancer la mobilisation contre les fuites
lancer la mobilisation contre le
gaspillage de l'eau potable multiplié la
possibilité de faire en sorte de
regarder les réutilisations d'eau nous
étions bien seuls à ce moment-là de ce
code erreur de l'hémicycle on était
plutôt dans le déballage des affaires de
vie privée que dans le souci de
s'occuper de ce qui relevait de l'état
écologique de la planète alors
maintenant vous évoquez un sujet que
vous connaissez mieux que moi parce que
le protocole vous l'avez signé en 2018
vous avez signé cet accord consistant à
réaliser des bassines et une étude de
juillet dernier une étude scientifique
conclue qui fait que ce sera bon pour
les étiages que ce sera bon pour les
débits ça n'est pas moi qui le dis c'est
l'étude du BRGM de juillet 2022 ce
projet il continue d'être soutenu par le
président à la Rousset par la présidente
du conseil départemental des Deux-Sèvres
et il a fait l'objet d'action en justice
qui ne se sont pas soldés par des
annulations moi je veux vous dire la
chose suivante oui la priorité ce sont
les nappes phréatiques c'est de diminuer
les prélèvements et les usages mais
faisons attention parce que l'eau pour
l'agriculture c'est l'eau pour se
nourrir ça n'est pas une privatisation
de l'eau deuxièmement il y a eu des
débordements faites attention à ne pas
provoquer des violences il y a un an des
gendarmes ont été blessés à l'occasion
de ce type de manifestation on peut pas
se lever pour leur rendre hommage et
pousser à la violence mais
[Applaudissements]
si madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je suis une opposante
démocratique à ce projet
et je connais par cœur la vieille
ficelle qui consiste à mettre en avant
les agissements violents d'une minorité
agissement que nous condamnons pour ne
pas entendre la voix d'une majorité
forte pacifiquement non violente qui
demande la raie de ce projet vous dites
qu'il est légal c'est ce qu'on disait de
l'aéroport de Notre-Dame-des-Landes vous
dites
merci la parole est à Madame Alma Dufour
pour le groupe la France insoumise
ça tombe bien ma question va aussi dans
ce sens ce dimanche en début de soirée
une tornade s'est abattue sur des
communes du Pas-de-Calais de la somme
des toits ont été arrachés certaines
maisons vont s'effondrer dans les
prochaines heures aujourd'hui 3000
foyers sont privés d'électricité je suis
à 35 ans de carrière je n'avais jamais
vu ça dans la Somme à déclaré un
lieutenant colonel évoquant une scène de
guerre de mots à peine après les feux de
forêt dont on a parlé qui ont forcé
l'évacuation de dizaines de milliers de
personnes le changement climatique
frappe donc de nouveau notre pays et
cela n'a rien étonnant mes chers
collègues car un nouveau rapport de
Météo France et du CNRS vient de
paraître et je dois vous le dire il a
réussi à me glacer le sang alors que je
défends la cause du climat depuis des
années les impacts du changement
climatique en France sont 50% plus
sévères que ce qui était jusqu'ici
estimé alors que nous devions limiter le
réchauffement planétaire à 1,5 degrés en
2100 en 2022 nous avons déjà atteint les
1,7 degrés en France nous attendrons
très probablement les 3,8 degrés la fin
du siècle avec mon collègue Sébastien
Rome nous sommes rapporteur spéciaux sur
l'adaptation au changement climatique
est-ce que nous avons découvert nous
laisse sans voix les scénarios sur
lesquels se base nos politiques
publiques d'adaptation étaient déjà trop
optimistes avant ce rapport ils sont
aujourd'hui complètement caduques la
stabilisation des effectifs dans les
services de l'écologie ne peut être une
réponse nous avons déjà réduit de 20%
ses effectifs c'est comme si notre
maison était en feu et que nous
annoncions fièrement arrêté de
l'asperger des sens il nous faudrait au
minimum 2 milliards de plus dans
l'adaptation au changement climatique
des EPLF alors tous nos amendements ce
sens ont été rejetés en commission des
finances avec les premiers injections
énoncés c'est l'économie française toute
entière qui risque de s'effondrer comme
les maisons de la somme que seront les
3% de déficit quand nous devrons nous
rationner en eau et que les rayons des
magasins seront à moitié vides ma
question est simple le gouvernement
va-t-il revoir d'urgence le scénario
d'adaptation au changement climatique en
fonction des données catastrophiques
produites par le CNRS et Météo France
deuxième question êtes-vous prêt à
adopter une augmentation immédiate de 2
milliards d'euros au fond dédiés à
l'adaptation au changement problématique
je vous remercie je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
Béchu ministre la transition écologique
et de la cohésion des territoires madame
la présidente madame la Première
ministre madame la députée du four
les rapports que vous évoquez qui font
suite au rapport du GIEC en avril au
rapport du Haut Conseil pour le climat
au mois de juin nous renforce dans la
nécessité d'établir cette feuille de
route de planification écologique dans
la première ministre a lancé les travaux
le 21 octobre dernier quand je vous ai
indiqué notre ambition de doubler le
rythme de baisse des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre j'ai été
raccourci par le fait que bien
évidemment ce conseil national il porte
sur l'atténuation sur l'adaptation et
sur la biodiversité qui ne doit pas être
l'angle mort des politiques climatiques
que nous conduisons au motifs que les
indicateurs pour la préservation de la
faune et de la flore sont parfois moins
complexes plus complexes pardon que les
questions de l'émission 4 milliards et
demi c'est la somme d'augmentation du
budget des crédits du ministère de
l'écologie pour l'année qui arrive dans
cela deux milliards d'euros pour les
collectivités locales qui pourraient
être fléchées sur ce type de crédit moi
je suis perdu madame la députée je suis
perdu entre ce que vous dites ici à la
tribune pour dire faites en sorte
d'ajouter les crédits et la manière dont
hier vous votez une motion de censure
allez voir vos copains de censure de
l'autre côté qui je crois ceux qui sont
climato défaitiste ceux qui sont
climato-sceptiques la vérité c'est que
vous appelez des choses de vos vœux et
que dans le même temps vous ne faites
pas preuve de cohérence l'action
climatique elle est de ce côté c'est la
Coface dont nous arrêt c'est le retrait
du traité de la charte de l'énergie
c'est les crédits qui augmentent c'est
le plan de relance du nucléaire c'est le
plan de relance sur les énergies
renouvelables les rendez-vous ils sont
devant vous votez ces crédits
rejoignez-nous dans ce combat au lieu de
rester dans des postures et au lieu de
rester uniquement dans des totems et
dans les modes
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Amélia la craie
pour le groupe Renaissance
madame la présidente madame la ministre
le Liban et Israël viennent de conclure
un accord historique et inespéré sur le
découpage de la frontière maritime entre
les deux pays et la délimitation de leur
zone économiques exclusives respectives
cet accord permettra l'exploitation et
l'exploration des ressources des
gazières au large de leur côte et
devraient ainsi contribuer à la
prospérité des deux étapes dans le Liban
notamment pays qui connaît une crise
sans précédent depuis l'explosion du
port de Beyrouth et dans lequel une
partie écrasante de la population s'est
paupériser
plus de 80% des Libanais vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté aujourd'hui l'espoir
suscité par les possibles retombées
économiques et immenses mais surtout cet
accord s'avère exceptionnel au vu du
passif et des tensions entre ces deux
pays toujours officiellement en état de
guerre il a fallu ainsi 11 ans 11 années
de négociation pour aboutir à ce
résultat permettant de solder l'un des
principaux conflits gaziers en
Méditerranée orientale même si l'on ne
veut pas encore parler de normalisation
des relations entre le Liban Israël il
s'agit incontestablement d'un pas
important pour la guerre et la paix dans
la région si le rôle des
États-Unis dans la négociation et bien
connue rappelons que la France est
également impliquée dans la recherche de
son compromis au travers l'action
diplomatique de notre président de la
République et de notre ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères cet
investissement était salué par le deux
états ainsi d'ailleurs que par le
président américain madame la ministre
je souhaite de ce fait vous interroger
sur le rôle qu'a joué notre pays sur la
conclusion de cet accord et avoir votre
avis sur la perspective qui l'ouvre pour
la stabilité régionale ainsi que la
résolution de la crise sociale et
politique au Liban
merci la parole est à Madame Laurence
bonne secrétaire des tâches âgé de
l'Europe merci merci madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
madame la députée Amélia la crêperie
vous avez raison c'est un accord
historique d'abord pour la région
puisqu'il montre que deux pays qui sont
en opposition peuvent se mettre d'accord
sur quelque chose d'essentiel et ensuite
pour le Liban lui-même puisque les
dirigeants se sont aussi mis d'accord
pour cette décision commune et oui la
France peut-être est fière du rôle
qu'elle a joué pour conclure cet accord
après cet accord comme vous l'avez fait
remarquer mais à la disposition la
majeure partie d'un shanghazier au Liban
dont on ne connaît pas encore toutes les
capacités et même s'il devait donner
beaucoup de gaz il ne résoudrait pas
tous les problèmes de Liban comme la
rappeler la ministre des Affaires
étrangères madame Colonna il y a deux
choses essentielles qui restent à faire
au Liban au moins deux pas
supplémentaires le premier c'est d'élire
un président il faut absolument qu'il
n'y ait pas de vacances de pouvoir et
que les dirigeants qui ont su se mettre
d'accord pour les frontières puissent
mettre d'accord pour élire un président
et la deuxième c'est de faire les
réformes nécessaires on peut penser à
trois la réforme du secret bancaire la
restructuration des banques et également
la
réforme pardon j'ai oublié et également
la loi sur le contrôle des capitaux bref
tout ce qui a trait au financier mais il
faut que les dirigeants nous aident à
les aider merci
je vous remercie madame la ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Stéphane co
pour le groupe GDR
merci madame la Présidente cette
question s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre vous avez déclaré dans cette
émission le 6 juillet dernier je vous
cite les Français ont élu une assemblée
sans majoritaire absolue il nous invite
à des pratiques nouvelles et à la
recherche active du compromis c'est donc
dans cet état d'esprit sans polémique et
solennellement que je vous pose cette
question
depuis plusieurs semaines l'UNICEF la
Fondation Abbé Pierre le Collectif des
associations unies des enseignants des
parents d'élèves et de nombreux
collègues ici présents vous appellent à
maintenir les 14000 places d'hébergement
d'urgence que vous envisagez de
supprimer dans le PLF alors que chaque
nuit en France entre 1700 et 2000
enfants dorment dehors sous un porche
dans une voiture où c'est un banc dans
un parc comment accepter ces fermetures
votre Ministre du Logement a reçu la
semaine dernière les associations
mobilisées sur le sujet il a prononcé
des paroles rassurantes qu'il a répété à
deux reprises lors des questions
gouvernement ici même malheureusement à
l'heure où nous parlons votre PDF
continue d'inscrire la suppression de
14000 places d'hébergement d'urgence or
les dispositifs qui existent sont déjà
saturés et c'est d'ailleurs pour cette
simple raison que des enfants dorment
chaque nuit à la rue Madame la première
ministre par-delà nos différences
politiques je pense qu'une certaine
vision humaniste de la France devrait
nous rassembler elle présume que
l'hébergement est un droit
inconditionnel comment comptez-vous le
garantir en procédant à de telles
fermetures allez vous prendre des
engagements pour le crédit dans la
mission cohésion des territoires soit
corrigés et que les belles paroles de
votre ministre se traduisent en actes
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur
ollain ministre délégué chargé de la
ville et du logement
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député Stéphane peu
je veux le redire ici la question des
familles avec des enfants à la rue est
aussi insupportable pour vous que pour
nous comme je vous l'avais annoncé la
semaine dernière avec Charlotte cobel
nous avons reçu comme vous l'avez
rappelé l'ensemble des associations
mobilisées sur cette question des
enfants à la rue et comme vous je salue
l'action de ces associations avec elle
nous avons décidé qu'une solution devait
être prouvée trouvée pour chacune des
familles et dès demain une nouvelle
réunion aura lieu avec l'ensemble de ces
associations la dyal les cabinets de nos
deux ministères pour continuer à trouver
des solutions et je sais les préfets
mobilisés dans chaque département pour
nous accompagner à trouver cette
solution en un mot je vais vous le dire
ce que la question de l'humanisme est
forcément partagée sur l'ensemble de nos
bancs aucun enfant ne doit dormir à la
rue cet hiver et nous travaillerons en
permanence pour faire que cette
situation ne soit pas acceptable je vais
vous le redire aussi il y a encore cette
semaine
197500 places d'hébergement d'urgence
dans ce pays c'est un chiffre qui
n'avait jamais été atteint avant la
crise sanitaire et ce chiffre est
toujours d'actualité mais oui oui la
situation est tendue dans un certain
nombre de nos territoires et en
particulier dans les grandes métropoles
c'est pour ça que nous travaillons à une
politique d'hébergement sur l'ensemble
du territoire national avec l'ensemble
des préfets je vais vous dire aussi que
l'action du gouvernement sous sous
l'autorité de la première ministre c'est
de faire que on passe de l'hébergement
d'urgence au logement d'abord que l'on
passe de la rue au logement et c'est une
priorité sur lequel nous allons
continuer à mettre l'accent et lancer le
deuxième plan logement d'abord il est
inscrit au PLF et nous tiendrons nos
engagements sur ce plan logement d'abord
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur le député peu
oui mais merci pour la réponse mais
arène à Strasbourg à Lyon dans la région
parisienne se mobilise des parents
d'élèves qui voient les les enfants
enfin ou les copains de leurs enfants
dormir à la rue et ça ne peut pas il n'y
aura pas de solution même au cas par cas
en continuant de supprimer 14000 places
d'hébergement d'urgence comme c'est
prévu il faut y revenir dessus le député
la séance des questions au Gouvernement
est terminée je vous propose de
suspendre quelques minutes avant de
reprendre pour le vote solennelle sur le
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques